ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND ADHERE TO SOCIAL
DANCE DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS T NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THIS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY ALTHOUGH
THAT IS NOT THE CASE TODAY.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS AS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED. THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK UP POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON YOU BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. OUR I. T. PERSON NOW
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON ME WHEN YOU
ARE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME. AND THEN YOU ARE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I'M ANNOUNCING IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO
SIX. EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO
TWO. FOUR SIX TWO. MORE DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE ANDORRA
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WEBSITE. SO
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR. TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE KNOW THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU ALSO MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE HERE AND MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. OR CUT OFF.
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED AND LASTLY FOR
EVERYONE PHYSICALLY PRESENT HERE
TODAY. PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASKS ON
COVERING YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT
ALL TIMES SO BEFORE WE BEGIN
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR
HACKER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR CALM WATER HERE
CABALLERO NIELSEN ROTH. RIGHT A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED BY
THE CONSULTANT WE WILL SKIP THE
VOTE ONLY SECTION AND WE'LL
REVISIT IT WHEN WE TAKE OUR
VOTES AT THE END. WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING ALL THE ISSUES LISTED
IN THE DISCUSSION SECTION OF THE
AGENDA TOGETHER WE WILL BEGIN
WITH O. P. R. O. P. R. WOULD YOU
PLEASE PRESENTS. AND THIS IS-
ITEMS SIX FIVE ZERO. WE'LL START
WITH ISSUE FIVE. GREAT THEY
DIDN'T TAKE HIM ON CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SAM A SUB-
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BINDING IN RESEARCH
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE AND CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT- CHAOS
BUDGET PROPOSALS INCLUDING
EDUCATION PRECISION MEDICINE
PROPOSED NEW OFFICE OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS. CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS AND LEGISLATIVE. I'LL
START WITH THE FIRST ISSUE ITEM
WHICH IS OPR EDUCATION PROPOSAL
. THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
LEARNING LAB FOR SALE WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO IMPROVE
LEARNING OUTCOMES AND CLOSE
EQUITY GAPS ON OUR PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
SPECIALLY THE KINDS OF GAPS WE
SEE FOR UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS. INTERESTED IN PURSUING
STEM FIELDS. SOUND IS NOW EARLY
IN ITS FOURTH YEAR OF OPERATION.
IT HAS AWARDED ALMOST TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO FIND
THIRTY NINE INNOVATIVE FACULTY
LED PROJECTS TO IMPROVE TEACHING
LEARNING AND STUDENT ACCESS.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF FACULTY
WHO ARE TAKING PART IN THIS
PROJECTS THAT ARE TOUCHING THE
LIVES OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS. WHILE THE STATE IS
INVESTING IN STUDENT SUCCESS IN
A VARIETY OF WAYS TO HELP YOU
NEWLY UNIQUELY WEAVES TOGETHER
THE SCIENCE OF HUMAN LEARNING.
THAT IS HOW STUDENTS ACTUALLY
LEARN. THE POWER OF TECHNOLOGY
THROUGH HYBRID AND ONLINE
LEARNING AND THE VALUES OF
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
TO HELP BUILD A MORE DYNAMIC
DIVERSE WORKFORCE THAT CAN HELP
THE STATE MEET THE CHALLENGES OF
THE FUTURE. THE BUDGET INCLUDES
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR A GRANT. TO THE
CARNEGIE SCIENCE CLIMATE
RESEARCH CLUB FACULTY IN
PASADENA. THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION LEARNING
LAB THREE STYLISH THE GOLDEN
STATE AWARDS GRANT PROGRAM FOR
THE PURPOSE OF INCENTIVIZING
CELEBRATING AND ELEVATING HIGH
IMPACT. INNOVATIONS CREATED IN-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- STAFF AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS SPECIFIC TO
THESE TWO PROPOSALS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. MAN STATE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE. AS
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON. SO WHEN I
THE PRIME TIME BRIAN DAHLE JEEZ
RIGHT. AND YES BRIAN WHEN- IF
YOU TO HEAR FROM THE OF FINANCE
FIRST FINE OTHERWISE I'D GO HEAD
. MY BAD. APOLOGIES BROWN
RELIGIOUS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AS OUTLINED BY THE
DIRECTOR. AND WE'RE OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS. OKAY GREAT THEY MAY
COME TO YOU OKAY NOW WILL HAVE
THE OTHER BRIAN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS SPRING WHETHER
FORD AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ARE A FULL
ANALYSIS OF THIS THESE ITEMS
AND- SEVERAL OTHER KEY APPEAR
BUDGET PROPOSALS I JUST WANTED
TO KNOW WILL BE PUBLISHED ON OUR
WEBSITE AS A BUDGET POST AT
THREE PM TODAY. I JUST WANT TO
APOLOGIZE THAT GIVEN THE BUDGET
ELSE'S TIME FRAME THIS YEAR WE
WERE UNABLE TO PROVIDE OUR
ANALYSIS IN ADVANCE. COME ON THE
HIGHER EDUCATION PROPOSALS- WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE PROPOSED
GOLDEN STATE AWARDS PROPOSAL
BECAUSE IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY POOR
DESIGN- WE'VE PREVIOUSLY NOTED
ON. THAT IN- PRIOR- WORD
INITIATIVES HAVE HAD
SHORTCOMINGS AND THIS. THIS
PROPOSAL. HAS SOME SIMILAR-
ISSUES ONE SHORTCOMING IS THAT
THE PROPOSAL WOULD. PROVIDE
RELATIVELY LARGE SUMS TO A SMALL
NUMBER OF RECIPIENTS WITHOUT ANY
CLEAR MECHANISM FOR
DISSEMINATING BEST PRACTICES AND
WE HAVE A RELATED CONCERN THAT
THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT PROVIDE A
CLEAR PLAN FOR SUSTAINING. AND
SCALING THE SELECTED ACTIVITIES
DISSEMINATING THE ACTIVITIES
MORE BROADLY COULD POTENTIALLY
CREATE CONSIDERABLE FUTURE COST
PRESSURES FOR THE STATE. AND WE
REYES ALSO CONCERNS THAT-
REWARDING EXISTING ACTIVITIES
HAS LIMITED ADDED VALUE- FINAL
CONCERNS SPECIFIC TO THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH IS- IT IT HAS A
BROADER SCOPE THAN PRIOR WORD
PROPOSALS RANGING FROM HIGHER
EDUCATION TO CLIMATE CHANGE TO
ANY OTHER AREA OF INTEREST THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THIS LACK OF
FOCUS ON THE CERTAINLY WOULD
UNDERMINE THE INITIATIVES
ABILITY TO MEANINGFULLY IMPACT
ANYONE AREA THE BROAD SCOPE ALSO
MEANS THE PROGRAM LIKELY
OVERLAPS WITH OTHER EXISTING
STATE EFFORTS SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
STATE HAS FUNDED RESEARCH ON
CLIMATE RELATED. ISSUES THROUGH
OTHER PROGRAMS AND DEPARTMENTS.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY COM ON
THESE I BUT I HAPPY TO. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU
I THINK BEFORE I GO FORWARD I'D
LIKE TO MAKE TWO COMMENTS ONE
SENATOR CABALLERO HAS. JOINED US
. SO MR HACKER I DON'T KNOW IF
FOR THE ROLE. SHE SHOULD STATE
SHE'S PRESENT- CABALLERO. AND I
ALSO WANT TO- SHARE THAT I'D-
SIMULTANEOUSLY SERVE ON RULES
WHICH IS HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME RIGHT ABOVE US SO THERE MAY
BE MOMENTS WHEN I HAVE TO STEP
OUT AND I WILL EXTEND THE GAVEL
TO OUR VICE CHAIR- SO WITH THAT
WE WILL NOW OPEN THE DISCUSSION
TO QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- SENATOR HOW I'LL GO
TO MY VICE CHAIR FOR SENATOR
NELSON DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
. SENATOR CABALLERO OUR PRIOR
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. YES MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ON
THIS ONE I HAD A REALLY HARD
TIME UNDERSTANDING EXACTLY WHAT
WAS. ANTICIPATED IN THE LEARNING
LAB PORTION OF THE OF THE GRANT
PROPOSAL- I KNOW IT PEDAGOGICAL
MEANS BUT WHEN WE START TALKING
IN. IN FACT YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE TERMS ARE
UNDERSTANDABLE NOT ONLY FOR US
BUT ALSO THE PUBLIC THE TAKES A
LOOK AT THIS AND SAYS- I THINK
INNOVATION GRANTS ARE TERRIFIC.
BUT BUT I REALLY AM INTERESTED
IN WHAT ARE THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE'RE EXPECTING FROM DOING THESE
GRANTS I'M AND I THINK A LOT OF
TIMES WE CREATE. PROGRAMS AND WE
DON'T HAVE STATED WHAT THE
OUTCOMES ARE AND I'M GONNA START
ASKING- THAT QUESTION A LOT MORE
IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE I'M NOT
SURE WE'RE GETTING GOOD BANG FOR
THE BUCK FOR WHAT WE'RE SPENDING
IN MANY IN MANY AREAS INSTANCES
IN AREAS SO I'M UP TOTALLY
COMMITTED TO STEM RESEARCH AND
UP. UP UP. CELEBRATING YOU KNOW
VICTORIES BUT FOR EXAMPLE THERE
WAS A PROGRAM THAT THAT FOCUSED
ON STEM. AND ONE OF THE GRANTS
WENT TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE A
CREATED A THREE YEAR COMPUTER
SCIENCE BE A PROGRAM WITH A
LOCAL- CSU AND SO THAT HEADS AS
SOME REAL OUTCOMES AND SOME REAL
SUCCESS STORIES. BECAUSE OF THAT
THAT THAT PROGRAM WAS. WAYS IT
COULD BE BETWEEN A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN SALINAS SENSE AND
THAT. CAL STATE MONTEREY BAY AND
THEY TOOK. YOUNG PEOPLE FROM OUR
COMMUNITY AND WITHIN THREE YEARS
AHEAD OF WORKING IN THE SILICON
VALLEY EARNING OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND A
MAJORITY OF THOSE WERE LIKE YOU
KNOW. AND AFRICAN AMERICAN YOUNG
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT- BEFORE SO
THAT HAS AN OUTCOME AND SO I'M
I'M I'M INTERESTED IN IN IN THAT
KIND OF- DETAIL AT WHEN WE WHEN
WE START TALKING ABOUT. ABOUT
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR RON
QUESTION OKAY- I WOULD JUST LIKE
SENATOR NIELSEN IF I MAY THIS IS
COME TO MIND THE- THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS OR P. R.'S
BECOME QUITE A- IN MY TERM.
BLOATED BUREAUCRACY. IT HAD A
VERY NARROW PURPOSE FOR MANY
YEARS AND NOW IT'S GONE WAY
BEYOND THAT IN MY OPINION. NOW
ONE OF THE PROPOSALS IS THE
LEARNING LAB. AND. SOME OF THE.
ROOT CAUSES OR STEM ISSUES.
AMONG GROUPS. I DON'T KNOW THAT
THIS IS GOING TO DEAL WITH IT.
THE QUESTION I HAVE THEN WHY
WOULD WITH WHAT JUSTIFIES.
MAKING THE THIRTEEN MILLION ON
GOING FUNDING. YOUR PERMANENT
OBLIGATION OF OUR BUDGET WHY WHY
IS THAT NECESSARY. CAN SOMEONE
FINANCE GIVE ME A THOUGHT. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION CENTER ALL
ALL JUST CLARIFY THAT SORT
PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS FOR THREE MILLION
ONGOING. FOR THE LEARNING LAB
WHICH IS B. AS YOU SAID BASTED
OPR THE TWO MILLION WOULD TWO
MILLION OF THAT THREE WOULD BE
TO RESTORE A DRAMATIC BUDGET
CUTS THE RESULTED FROM THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT- SO
THAT'S THAT'S OUR- OUR VIEW IS
THAT THAT'S NEEDED TO BRING THE
PROGRAM UP TO WHERE IT WAS WHEN
IT WAS AN INVASION. SO THERE IS
AN ADDITIONAL ONE MILLION THEY
WERE PROPOSING TO AUGMENT THAT
WOULD BE TO FIND A PROGRAM THAT
IS CURRENTLY COME OUT OF THE
EXISTING CELL GRANTS. AND WE SEE
AS A GREAT SUCCESS IT'S
SPECIFICALLY WOULD MAKE LOWER
DIVISION CHEMISTRY COURSES-
BASICALLY HELP TEXTBOOK COSTS
FALL O ALMOST ZERO MAKE THE
MORE CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE AND-
BE DESIGNED IN A NEW- INNOVATIVE
WAY THAT'S GONNA HELP- PROMOTE
STEM IN GENERAL AND ALTERNATELY
HIGH PAID JOBS FOR CALIFORNIANS.
SO FOR US THIS ONE MILLION IT'S
CURRENTLY BEEN A ONE TIME GRANT
T. MAKING IT ONGOING THAT'S
GOING TO CREATE BIG- COST
SAVINGS FOR STUDENTS EVENTUALLY
SO FOR THE EDUCATION SIDE THIS.
IS A BIG EXCITING PROPOSAL. YOUR
EXPECTING THE WE THE COMMITTEE
SHOULD NOT RE EVALUATE THAT
EVERY SINGLE YEAR. IT SHE LIKE
THAT ME VERY IRRESPONSIBLE WHAT.
ON IN TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY AS
THE GOVERNING OF DOES PUT OUT
ANNUAL REPORTS IN TERMS OF ITS
ACTIVITIES AND- PROVIDES DETAILS
ON ITS ITS GRAND SIX CENTER AND
THIS WOULD WOULD BE BAKED INTO
THEIR- YOU KNOW THEY PROVIDE
UPDATES. BUT THE POINT I MAKE IS
. THAT'S NOT OVERSIGHT ANNUAL
REPORTS. FOR ME OR JUST KIND OF
NONSENSE. IT'S COVERING THE BASE
PRETENDING THAT YOU'RE REALLY
DOING SOMETHING WHAT ARE THE
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO IMPOSE HERE. THE
CRITERIA. TO JUSTIFY YOUR
ACTIONS THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
WE PROPOSE TO DO THIS TWO
MILLION RESTORATION OF TWENTY
TWENTY CUTS IN THE ONE MILLION
AUGMENTATION FOR THECHEMISTRY
FOCUSED OUR UNDERGRADUATE
INNOVATIVE PLATFORM THAT DAD WE
DON'T HAVE IN BBL WE DON'T HAVE
DETAILED PERFORMANCE METRICS THE
JUSTIFICATION THERE IS THAT IT'S
ESSENTIALLY A PILOT PROGRAM THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING TO SCALE. AND SO
THEY ARE IN THE IT PART OF THE
PROPOSAL IS THAT IN THE FIRST
YEAR OF PERMANENT FUNDING THEY
WOULD BUILD OUT A MULTI YEAR
PLAN- SO WE'RE THEY'RE SORT OF
PUTTING TOGETHER FROM PILOT TO
SCALING PHASE AND THINKING
THROUGH WHAT METRICS MIGHT EVEN-
HE ACHIEVABLE. THANK YOU SIR I
DON'T BUY THAT AT ALL BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ANSWER. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON I AM. JUST
QUICKLY WANT TO ECHO SOME OF
THE- THOUGHTS AND CONCERNS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES. SINCE WE DON'T
EVEN NOW IF THIS IS GONNA WORK-
THE QUESTION IS A Y. HERE
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THEY'RE
ANY. IS NOT DRIVEN BY ANY KIND
OF STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITIES SO
THAT'S THE FIRST QUESTION WHY NO
PR AND THEN THE SECOND QUESTION
IS IF WE DON'T EVEN KNOW IF IT
WILL WORK Y. AS SEEMS PRETTY
PRESUMPTION WAS TO. ASK FOR ON
GOING FUNDING. FINANCE. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS IN ALL
JUST ALL ASSUME WE'RE STILL AND
NOT MY APOLOGIES IF THIS IS NOT
CORRECT BUT I'M ASSUMING WE'RE
GOING TO STILL TALK ABOUT THE-
THREE MILLION ONGOING PROPOSED
FOR THE LEARNING LAB
SPECIFICALLY. AND SO FOR THE AT
TWO MILLION RESTORATION. OUR OWN
IT WHICH IS THE BIGGEST PIECE OF
IT. THE CELL LEARNING LAB WAS
CREATED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN- THE
TRAILER BILL TO THE BUDGET ACT
AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE. AND THE
ORIGINAL GRANT POOL THAT THEY
HAD TO PROVIDE INTERSECTING
FACULTY GROUPS- AGGRESSIVE-
INNOVATIVE LIKE STEM FOCUSED.
SHIFTS IN TEACHING AND EDUCATING
UNDERGRADUATES THAT GRANT POOL
WAS AT TEN MILLION THEY WERE
LATER CUT DOWN TO EIGHT MILLION
SO WE'RE SENSUALLY TRYING TO
PROPOSE LET'S GO BACK TO HOW THE
PROGRAM WAS ORIGINALLY THAT'S
THE BIGGEST PIECE OF THIS
PROPOSAL THE SECOND PIECE WHICH
I IT SOUNDS LIKE SENATORS ARE
CONCERNED WE'RE FOCUSED ON IS
THE AUGMENTATION TO TAKE ONE OF
THE CURRENT GRANTEES MAKE IT ON
GOING- WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CONCERNS YOU'RE YOU'RE VOICING.
BUT IN OUR VIEW THIS IS AN
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY
SPECIFICALLY IN THE HIGHER ED
WORLD FOR US THINGS THAT
OTHERWISE WE WOULDN'T HAVE THIS
TYPE OF INTERSEGMENT ALL
COLLABORATION HAPPENING WITHOUT
THIS PROGRAM. I SEE MISS LARK
PARK HAS HER HAND UP. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO
ADD ON- THE ONE MILLION-
AUGMENTATION ONGOING
AUGMENTATION THAT'S BEING
REQUESTED FOR ONE OF OUR OUR
GRANT PROJECTS THERE ARE REALLY
THREE DIMENSIONS OF VALUE THAT
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT HAS THAT
ARE UNIQUE ONE IS ABOUT COST TO
STUDENTS ABOUT TAX THE COST TO
STUDENTS- VERY VERY MANY
STUDENTS TAKE GENERAL CHEMISTRY
IN THESTATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
SO HAVING SOMETHING OF THAT IS
FREE FOR THEM THAT COULD BE
UNIFORMLY USE ACTUALLY HAS A
MULTIPLE AND- RATIO VALUE IN
TERMS OF THE STATE'S INVESTMENT
A SECOND DIMENSION OF VALUE IS-
THAT ADHD. FIVE IS- IT CORPORATE
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE CULTURALLY
SUSTAINING MATERIALS WITHIN THE
COURSE AND ONE OF THINGS THAT
MANY OF OUR GRANTEES- ARE
WORKING ON IT IS STUDENTS SENSE
OF BELONGING ESPECIALLY FOR
UNDER RECORDS SENATE STUDENTS.
AND BAGS- HAVING STUDENTS-
MAINTAIN THEIR PATHWAY TO SPAM-
WHEN THEY ARE AT RISK RIGHT
UNDER UNDER REPRESENTATIVE OR
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE IN THE
MINORITY- IS SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A GREAT
VALUE IN KEEPING STUDENTS ON A
STEM PATHWAY THAT WILL THEN NEED
TO THE STEM JOBS THE THIRD IS-
TECHNOLOGY VALUE WHICH IS REALLY-MAKING USE OF. NEW TECHNOLOGIES
ADAPTIVE LEARNING TECHNOLOGIES.
TO AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
THIS IS CUTTING EDGE AND HOW A
LOT OF LEARNING TO BE DONE IN
THE FUTURE AND SAID THIS PROJECT
ACTUALLY REPRESENTS A
COMBINATION OF UNIQUE VALUES I
THAT I AT THAT ARE AT THE
CUTTING EDGE. OF EDUCATION.
RIGHT THE DOUBLES ALWAYS IN THE
DETAILS SO. CENTER NIELSEN. LET
ME TRYTHAT THIS DEBATE AGAIN
AND- RESPECTFULLY I HAVE GOT TO
RESPOND USE THE WORD FREE. I
KIND OF TAKE OFFENSE AT THIS
FREE. BUT BUT HERE'S THE POINT
GETTING BACK TO YOUR A WARNING
ANY PERFORMANCE STANDARDS STRICT
STANDARDS- LET THINGS JUST WORK
OUT WE'LL SEE. IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT'S BEEN VERY
EVIDENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS
THAT WE JUST STATE THE HIGH TECH
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD CANNOT GET
IT RIGHT. THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN. TAXES AFTER
TECHNOLOGICAL UPGRADES IN OUR-
VARIOUS AGENCIES YOU NAME THE
AGENCY. FISCAL MILLION THE MOST
RECENT. THESE PROJECTS DO NOT
COME IN ON BUDGET. THE ALWAYS
GET EXPANDED SOMEWHERE ALONG THE
WAY CONTRACTS GET AMENDED. IT'S
AN EMBARRASSMENT. THE STATE
SENATE ITSELF THE COMMUNICATIONS
CONTINUE TO BREAK DOWN. THE NEW
BUILDING THAT WE ARE NOW
OCCUPIED. I DON'T WANT TO SAY
IT'S A DISASTER BUT LET'S JUST
SAY IT'S NOT VERY FUNCTIONAL AT
THIS POINT. AND WE'RE SPENDING A
LOT OF MONEY AT IT. GETS BACK TO
MY POINT THAT I WANT TO SEE
DELIVERABLES. WANT TO SEE
CONSEQUENCES IF THE PROVIDER.
THE CONTRACTOR DOES NOT. DELIVER
AND THAT THAT BE WRITTEN INTO
OUR CONTRACTS. WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET IT RIGHT
. IN THE OFFICE OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND I DO NOT KNOW IF
THAT'S THE CURRENT. NAME OF THAT
AGENCY. IT'S SINGULAR
ACHIEVEMENT OVER THE DECADES IS
JUST BEEN TO KEEP CHANGING ITS
NAME. BUT HASN'T MADE ANYTHING
BETTER NOW SHOULD WE IMPOSE SOME
STANDARDS ON THAT AGENCY THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO THE FACT GREATER
EFFICIENCY. AND DELIVERY OF
THESE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A
PROJECT ABSOLUTELY. SO I JUST
HAVE TO SAY I'M GOING TO BE OF.
VERY RESISTANT- TO THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU VICE CHAIR AND
I JUST HAVE TWO QUICK QUESTIONS
ONE HOW WAS THE CARNEGIE
SCIENCE- HUB IDENTIFIED. AND I
GUESS THIS IS THE FOR FINANCE OR
OPR- BRIAN COULD RESPOND TO THAT
AGAIN FROM D. O. F. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR SERVER. BROWN RELIGIOUS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THE
CARNEGIE SCIENCE. THEY'RE
THEY'RE LOOKING TO CONSOLIDATE
OPERATIONS FOCUSED ON
ENVIRONMENT AND CLIMATE. IN
PASADENA AND DAVE THEY'VE
ESTIMATED A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION AS THE TOTAL COST FOR A
NEW FACILITY THAT WOULD HOUSE
THIS THIS CONSOLIDATION OF
EXISTING STAFF AND EXPANDING
STAFF. HI WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
LOCATING THAT IN CALIFORNIA. AND
IT WAS DETERMINED THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY THEY HAVE PRIVATE
FUNDS A CAMPAIGN GOING ON NOW
CAPITAL CAMPAIGN FOR THE
FACILITY- THAT THE STATE. COULD
COULD I WOULD COULD MAKE A
CRITICAL CONTRIBUTION WITH
TWENTY MILLION- OUR OUR VIEW IS
THAT WE'RE WE'RE NOT AWARE OF
THE EXACT AMOUNT OF PRIVATE
FUNDING THEY HAVE AT THIS POINT
WE KNOW THAT ARE TWENTY MILLION
WOULD NOT SUPPLANT IN THE
EXISTING FARMS SO THAT THIS
WOULD ACTUALLY BE CRITICAL TO
THEM. PULLING THIS OFF SO WE ARE
. WE VIEW THIS AS A GREAT STEP
FORWARD IN THE CLIMATE CHANGE
MITIGATION AND ADAPTATION.
AGENDA FOR THE STATE. ALSO JUST
ADDED I MEAN IT'S IMPORTANT
CONTEXT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS A BIG. CLIMATE PACKAGE THIS
BUDGET THERE'S BILLIONS ACROSS.
EVERY AREA FROM HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION HIGHER EDUCATION
ETCETERA- AND SO THIS TWENTY
MILLION IS JUST. IN OUR VIEW
JUST SORT OF A SMALL PIECE OF
THE- LET'S LET'S ADVANCE
RESEARCH LABS- TRANSITION JOBS
ETCETERA SO THIS IS LIKE A BIG.
PART OF A BIGGER VISION. I
APPRECIATE THAT THERE ARE
HUNDREDS I'M SURE OF OTHER
CORPORATIONS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS DOING WORK IN THE
CLIMATE SPACE SO THE QUESTION IS
REALLY COULD BE- SELECTION OF
THE CARNEGIE SCIENCE HUB STAND
UP TO SCRUTINY IF FOLKS WANTED
TO KNOW. WHY THEY WERE SELECTED
OVER SOMEONE ELSE. SO THEN THE
LAST THE SECOND QUESTION IS
THEIR CRITERIA FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE AWARDS GRANT PROGRAM
BECAUSE SIMILAR TO THE COMMENTS
OF SENATOR CABALLERO EVERYONE
LOVES INNOVATION GRANTS. AND
COMPETITIVE GRANTS BUT YOU ALSO
HAVE TO HAVE CRITERIA AND
GUARDRAILS AND SOME TRANSPARENCY
AROUND HOW THOSE ARE GOING TO
BE- WHAT THEY ARE AND HOW THEY
WILL BE. SORT OF-
OPERATIONALIZED SO I KNOW THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM YOU MIGHT
NOT HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS BUT-
YOU'LL HAVE TO GET ON. WE
APPRECIATE THAT I CAN JUST OFFER
OUR OUR OUR PROPOSAL AS IT
STANDS IN BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
THE THERE'S TWO WAYS THAT THE-
THE THIRTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. WORDS WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BEEF. END UP IN
GRANTEES HANDS THE FIRST FILTER
WOULD BE WE HAVE SOME
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA- WE CALL
OUT IN BBL THAT- POTENTIAL
ELIGIBLE- INDIVIDUALS OR TEAMS
FOR NOMINATIONS WOULD INCLUDE
INSTRUCTORS AT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES- RESEARCHERS. THAT
THEY WORK ON CLIMATE CHANGE THE
OTHER BIG FILTER IS THAT THE
SELECTION COMMITTEE B. B. L.
SPECIFIES THERE'D BE TWELVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THE
SELECTION COMMITTEE THEY WOULD
COME FROM A BROAD RANGE OF.
RAFEAL SAID IN A STAPLER GROUP
SO WE HAVE A BUNCH OF EXPERTISE
THERE- IT DELEO HAS CRITICIZED
THIS AS TOO BROAD IN OUR VIEW
THAT'S THE STRENGTH WE THINK
THAT HAVING A SELECTION
COMMITTEE FROM MULTIPLE
PERSPECTIVES. IS GONNA BE HOW
THIS THIS OFFERS- THE WAY OF
IDENTIFYING STATEWIDE CONCERNS
THAT THAT NEED RECOGNITION FOR
PLACES WHERE INNOVATION IS
HAPPENING- SO- THAT'S THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT SATISFACTORY IN
TERMS OF THE THEIR WINTER RACING
BUT I THINK THAT'S OUR
PERSPECTIVE. WELL YOU KNOW WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO HAVE A STARTING
POINT SO- WE'RE NEXUS SINCE I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER FOLKS
INTERESTED IN COMMENTING WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
DISCUSSION ITEM WHICH IS ISSUE
NUMBER SIX. PRECISION MEDICINE
PROPOSALS- OPR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
START US OFF. YES THANK YOU
NUMMINEN CHAIR- AS PART OF OPR
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE TO ADVANCE
THE PRECISION MEDICINE PROGRAM
OR- KNOWN AS SITE COM. WILL
REQUESTING ABOUT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GENERAL
FUNDS TO PROVIDE. GRANTS FOR
PROJECTS FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY
ON DEPRESSION. OUR DATA PLUG
THAT PRECISION MEDICINE APPROACH
TO USING BETA IN COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SETTINGS. A
STRONG FOCUS FOCUS OF THIS
RESEARCH PROGRAM WITH THE GOALS
OF HEALTHEQUITY INCLUDING
REQUIREMENTS TO PARTNER WITH-
COMMUNITIES AND- PRIORITIZE
RESEARCH THAT DRIVES PROGRESS.
IN PROVIDING SOLUTIONS FOR-
DISPROPORTIONATELY UNDERSERVED
AREA THE GRANTS WILL AWARD-
APPROXIMATELY THREE TO FIVE
PROJECTS APPLYING A PRECISION
MEDICINE APPROACH TO USING USING
DATA IN COUNTY BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH SETTINGS- AND PARTNERING
WITH COMMUNITIES AND
PRIORITIZING RESEARCH AGAIN THAT
PROVIDES SOLUTIONS FOR-
DISPROPORTIONATELY. UNDERSERVED
AREAS. WE ARE ALSO READ. NINE
THREE DOLLARS DURING- PARTS OF
UNDER REPRESENTED. IN BIOMEDICAL
RESEARCH TO LEAD AND I'M
INTERNET AGENCY COOPERATION TO
DEVELOP BEST PRACTICES CREATE
PROMOTIONAL MATERIALS AND HOST
EVENTS TO RAISE AWARENESS AND
INCREASED. PARTICIPATION AMONG
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND MEDICAL
RESEARCH STUDIES THE FIVE YEAR
PROJECT WILL. JUMPSTART A BROAD
PUBLIC PRIVATE COALITION TO
IMPROVE APPROACHES TO ENGAGING
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES IN RESEARCH
AND DIVERSE TO ENSURE THAT NEXT
GENERATION MEDICINES AND DISEASE
PREVENTION STRATEGIES THAT
BENEFIT ALL CALIFORNIANS. I
HAVE- AND STOP BY A CO DIRECTOR
JULIAN AND A CALL HERE FROM SITE
COM AT TO SIR ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I. THINK NOW WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. KEVIN CLARK WITH BERMAN OF
FINANCE- WE JUST MIRROR- PR'S
ARE COMMENTS ON THIS SUMMER
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS
WELL. OKAY GREAT EN LA- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENT
. YES THIS IS BRIAN WEATHERFORD
AGAIN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO WE HAVEN'T
DEVELOPED- I'LL TRY TO KEEP IT
FREE I WEEK WE HAVE A DEVELOP
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
DEPRESSION RESEARCH COMPOSITION
RESEARCH PROPOSAL BECAUSE- WE
GENERALLY FIND IT CHALLENGING TO
EVALUATE THESE PRECISION
MEDICINE PROPOSALS GIVEN THE
LACK OF A STATE WIDE FRAMEWORK
FOR PRIORITIZING THE ALLOCATION
OF STATE FUNDING. FOR SPECIFIC
RESEARCH MEDICINE TOPICS OVER
OTHER RESEARCH AREAS ARE GENERAL
FUNDING FOR ACADEMIC RESEARCH-
THAT'S IN AND WE HAVE SOME
LONGSTANDING CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PRECISION MEDICINE RESEARCH.
AREA THAT THAT THAT WE PROVIDED
IN THE PAST SO I'M A BELIEVER
THAT POINT. I WILL- MENTION IN
THE AGENDA THAT. IS MENTIONED IN
THE AGENDA THE INSTITUTE EVENTS
PRECISION MEDICINE IS JUSTIFIED
CONTINUED- STATE FUNDING FOR
SELECTED AREAS OF PRECISION
MEDICINE TO HELP PLUG GAPS IN
THE FEDERALLY FUNDED RESEARCH.
THAT IT RECEIVES BUT- ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S NOT SUPPORTED
THIS WITH A DETAILED GAP
ANALYSIS HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR FUNDING CERTAIN. AREAS
OF RESEARCH OVER OTHERS WE DO
HOWEVER FIND THAT THE PROPOSAL
TO INCREASE THE FIRST
PARTICIPATION AND BIOMEDICAL
RESEARCH PROJECTS COULD HAVE
MERIT. SOME GROUPS HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY TO REPRESENTED IN
BIOMEDICAL RESEARCH IN THIS IS
LIKE TO DOCUMENT AND HEALTH
DISPARITIES. WELL THIS EFFORT
COULD POSSIBLY DUPLICATE OTHER
FEDERALLY LED EFFORTS TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION IN THE
STUDIES NATIONALLY. THIS
PROPOSAL- APPEARS THAT IT WOULD
BE FOR FOCUSED ON INCREASING
PARTICIPATION AMONG THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE STATE
SPECIFICALLY AND SO THERE MAY BE
SOME BENEFIT TO HAVING AFFECTS.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU NOW- HI WE
WILL OPEN UP FOR DISCUSSION
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER VICE OKAY NOW
ALL RIGHTS AND- CABALLERO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- THAT THE
QUESTION I HAVE IN REGARDS TO-
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL. IS-
YOU KNOW THAT THE WORDS ALL
SOUND REALLY GREAT I THINK THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS- EXACTLY.
EXACTLY HOW. THE A PRECISION
MEDICINE APPROACH WELL FIRST OF
ALL IS DOES THIS REALLY BELONG
AN OPR. AT LEAST I UNDERSTAND
THAT'S WHERE IT WOULD BE HOUSE-
AND WHY IS IT NOT IN- IN OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR HEALTHSECTOR-
AND THEN TO IS- IF IT IS IT IT
IT IT APPEARS AT AYE AYE SUPPORT
PROJECTS THAT REALLY THE FOCUS
ON DEPRESSION AND I DON'T I
THINK THERE CANNOT BE A BETTER
TIME. FOR US TO FOCUS ON
DEPRESSION- AND I'M- WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES. SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE OUT. HOW WE
HELP PEOPLE- AND SO THE IDEA OF
DOING IT IT AND BROADER. IN IN
TERMS OF- TREATMENTS THE TREATY
GROUP AS OPPOSED TO INDIVIDUALS
REALLY APPEALS TO ME AND SO I
JUST I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT HOW- HOW
WE USE PRECISION MEDICINE IN
THIS PARTICULAR. INSTANCE GIVEN
THAT AS I UNDERSTAND IT IT LOOKS
AT GENETICS ENVIRONMENT AND
LIFESTYLE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
TREATMENT SHOULD BE AND- I'M NOT
. I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE WHAT
THE OUTCOMES THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR AND EXACTLY WHAT ARE WE
GONNA GET AFTER WE SPENT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. ARE ON ON A- ON
A ON A PROJECT THAT THEY DON'T
DETER ST A FIVE. THREE TO FIVE
PROJECTS AND WHERE THOSE
PROJECTS ARE LOCATED BECOMES
REALLY IMPORTANT YES TWO YOU
KNOW WHAT THE WHAT THE GROUPS OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE BEING
STUDIED SO I GUESS I JUST NEED
MORE INFORMATION ANDERSON
EXACTLY HOW THIS. THIS
PARTICULAR GRANT WOULD WORK. SO
IS THE DETAIL IS IMPORTANT
DETAILS ARE IMPORTANT MARIA-
MAIL SENT. IF ON THAT AND THIS
IS GOING TO BE IN ONGOING THING
. IT SEEMS LIKE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRO. GET AN IDEA THE SOMETHING
SOUNDS CONTEMPORARY INTERESTING
TO THEM IMPORTANT OR AN AGENCY
TO BUILD THIS BUREAUCRACY OR ITS
BUDGET. AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THAT
POPS UP IN MANY AGENCY BUDGETS.
THROUGHOUT GOVERNMENT. AND IT'S
PRETTY TOUGH FOR US TO KEEP
TRACK OF IT. OUR SUB COMMITTEE
CAN SCRUTINIZE IT. BUT THEN IT'S
KINDA LOST IN THE SHUFFLE. AND
THEN I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE THE
LEDGE ANALYST BECAUSE I THINK
THEY WOULD DO THAT WITH THE
FURNACE THAT. OTHER ENTITIES
WOULD NOT. WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR. IN THESE
AREAS. RESEARCH AND APPLICATION
THE PRECISION MEDICINE. WHY DOES
IT ALL HAVE TO BE COME VESTED IN
GOVERNMENT OR SO MUCH OF IT SO
MANY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. NOW
THIS IS. BUDGET DUST MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
OUR BUDGETS PLURAL. DEPARTMENT
BUDGETS ARE FULL. OF THESE GOOD
IDEAS. SO I BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO REQUIRE A LOT MORE
SCRUTINY. AND A LOT MORE
PRESCRIPTION PRESCRIPTION ON HOW
MONIES ARE TO BE EXPENDED.
BEFORE THE EGISLATURE SHOULD
VOTE YES FOR MORE MONEY. SENATOR
NIELSEN I MEAN SENATOR ROB.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I GUESS I
WILL MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS YOU
KNOW I WAS AROUND THE- I BELIEVE
THAT THE INCEPTION- OF THIS
PRECISION MEDICINE- JOURNEY IN
THIS COMMITTEE AND I WAS. THOSE
WHO WERE THERE AND- PEER AT THE
TIME THEY RECALL- THAT I WAS
SOMEWHAT CRITICAL OF THE
PROPOSALS THEN. AS TO THE NATURE
OF THE RESEARCH- PRECISION
MEDICINE RESEARCH IN THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT THAT. IT COULD
OR WAS PROPOSED TO HAVE GIVEN OF
COURSE THE LEVEL OF FUNDING. BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH
THE- THE N. I. H. HOWEVER-
THROUGH THE PASSAGE OF TIME I
NOW RECOGNIZE THAT THE IN FACT
GOVERNMENT HAS A ROLE. IN THIS
TYPE OF INNOVATIVE ENERGY
RESEARCH. AND THAT AS A STATE AS
LARGE AS WE ARE IN THIS STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE CAN'T COUNT ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO DO THE
SPECIFIC TYPE OF HEALTH RELATED
RESEARCH THAT WE REALLY NEED IS
A STATE. TO DO ARE HEALTH
RELATED- PLANNING AND
PROGRAMMING. AND AS TO METRIC
SIDE YOU KNOW I CAME OUT OF THE
MILITARY AND- THOSE OF YOU
WHO'VE BEEN AROUND THE BUDGET.
FOR THE TIME THAT I'VE BEEN HERE
AND YOU'VE BEEN IN COMMITTEES
THAT I'VE BEEN PRIVILEGED TO SIT
ON YOU'VE HEARD ME. GIVE A
LITTLE LECTURE PERIODICALLY
ABOUT METRICS AND HELP METRICS
ARE CRITICAL. IN ANYTHING WHERE
WE SPEND MONEY HOWEVER. I ALSO
THINK KIM BELIEVES THAT WITH
THIS TYPE OF INNOVATIVE RESEARCH
IT'S FAIRLY DIFFICULT. TO INSIST
ON THE TYPE OF PERFORMANCE
METRICS THAT I WOULD NORMALLY.
OTHERWISE INSIST ON IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS SO- I. I'M A
BELIEVER AND I THINK THERE IS
VALUE IN THIS RESEARCH IN THE
MONEY THAT WE DIRECT TOWARD IT
TO I BELIEVE IT IS HAD IMPACT
SINCE. OF THE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN BUDGET WHEN I WAS HERE
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND I INTEND
TO SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL- IF AND
WHEN IT COMES FORWARD FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUSS I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS- FOR. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- OR THE ALEJO'S OFFICE-
BUT I SEE SAM YOU HAVE YOUR HAND
REYES. A YES THANK YOU SENATORS
OF THESE ARE ALL IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS I JUST WANNA- I'M
GOING TO CALL ON- A CHILLY AND
MCCALL TO ANSWER SOME OF THE-
BEST JUST A COUPLE OF- YOU KNOW
THE Y. O. PR- SPECIFICALLY FOR
THIS IN ONE OF THE ROLE.
INSPECTION ROLE OF WILL BE OUR
IS WORK ACROSS THE STATE
AGENCIES SO WE WORK AND WORK
WITH ACROSS. A BROAD-
STAKEHOLDERS SO THAT IS PART OF
THE ROLE OF OPR AND I WASN'T
HERE WHEN. PRECISION MEDICINE
WAS PUT IN THERE ARE BAD. I DO
SEE THE ROLE AS AN AGENCY THAT
IS CHARGED WITH. CONNECTING THE
DOTS ON A LOT OF ISSUES- I
BELIEVE IT MAKES SENSE THAT ON
THE SECOND. PART I THINK- I
BELIEVE COVER HOUSE ROLE IN THE
SPECIFIC REDUCE ISSUES IN.
RELEVANCE TRUE HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN RESEARCH ON
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WE KNOW
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR RESEARCH
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS RESEARCH IS
DONE ON PEOPLE OF COLOR AND SOME
OF THE WORK THAT CYCLONE HAS
DONE IS REALLY FOCUSED ON THAT.
SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT UP
BUT I'M GONNA CALL JULIAN
MCCALL- CODIRECTOR SIDE COMES ON
SIR- A COUPLE OF YOUR QUESTIONS
IN TERMS OF WHY- WHY AROUND THE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR. BYE AND
UNDER AFTERNOON MA'AM CARE AND
OF THE COMMITTEE- THERE ARE
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS THAT THEIR
SENSE- I WOULD. LOVE TO HEAR
PROVIDE RESPONSES ALL OF THEM
BUT I RESPECT YOUR TIME THE
ONLY. A FEW. THE LACK OF
MEASUREMENT FOR ACADEMIC
RESEARCH IN FACT WE CONDUCT. A
RIGOROUS EXTERNAL OUT OF STATE-
EXPERT BODY PROCESS- CAN BRING
TO LIGHT ALL OF THE- IMPACT OF
THOSE PROJECTS AND WE MAINTAIN
RELATIONSHIPS WITH EACH OF
THOSE. RESEARCH TEAM- FIVE YEARS
FOLLOWING THE CONCLUSION OF THE
PROJECT IN ORDER TO CAPTURE ALL
THE NEW PATENT. THE PATENT
EXTENSIONS- THE NEW FTA- AT
INNOVATION FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF
OUR PROJECT- CONTRIBUTED TO THE
FDA'S FIRST EVER APPROVAL OF AN
IMAGING BIOMARKER- THERE ARE
ALSO RESULT WHY. OUR RESEARCH
CONTRIBUTED TO- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BEING ABLE TO TRACK.
HOW THE VIRUS MUTATING IN
CALIFORNIA THE HARD CODED TO
VIRUS- THAT WAS KIND OF A DREAM
COME TRUE IMPACT FOR ANY
RESEARCH. PROGRAMS WILL SUCCEED
AND SEE THE IMPACT- SO. AFTER
FINDING THAT WOULD ONLY FEW
YEARS AFTER THAT PROJECT WAS
FUNDED. ON WE ARE AT THE SENATOR
NIELSEN SCOTT ABOUT- THE HEALTH
SPREAD NAY- HOPE. AND GET HEALTH
- I IN FACT- THAT WE MENTIONED
THAT HELP TO MISTER BY SUMMARY
THAT MAKES THAT THOSE ARE PRO
ARE RUSSIA- HUGH- ROAD. FOR THE
GOVERNOR AND ASSISTED THE
SURGEON GENERAL AND WRITING THE
SURGEON GENERAL'S REPORT ALL ON
THE SIDE LITERALLY IN THE
EVENINGS AND WEEKENDS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT LED GOVERNOR
GOVERNMENT'S PRIORITIES ARE ARE-
IT COME TO FRUITION- AND IN
TERMS OF WHY WE ARE NOT IN. ASIA
ARE. YOU KNOW OPR OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH WE LOOK AT
THE OF OURSELVES AND PUTTING THE
ART OPR- BUT WE ARE A TO THAT.
RANGE OF WHAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING AND
NEEDS AND THERE ARE NO RESEARCH
SCIENTIST IN ANY OTHER AGENCY TO
THE DEGREE THAT WE ARE FOCUSED.
ON FOR ABLE TO BE NIMBLE ABLE TO
RESPOND- IN AS QUICKLY AS
RESEARCH. CAN AT OF HE JACKIE
PLAN- INTO TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE-
ARE- THE MATTER A REPORT
PRECISION MEDICINE ASKING FOR
HELP WHERE ALL OF STRATEGY
INCLUDE THE NEW PROPOSAL ARE LAY
OUT IN THE- THE SENATOR WILL WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- SO LET'S USE
THAT A LONG- ADVOCATE FOR- WE
ADD TO ARE DEEPLY GREAT. FOR THE
GUY ON A WHERE GO OUR NEXT
OPPOSED. AND TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
. THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT I DON'T
ANY OTHER HANDS RAISED FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THE
SERVER CABALLERO NO JUST THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT INFORMATION
I FOUND IT VERY VERY HELPFUL.
CRUCIATUS THANK YOU. SO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT DISCUSSION ITEM WHICH IS
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS OPR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO FIRST. AND SET US UP
SURE I'M SURE SO- THIS IS A NEW
PROPOSED OFFICE WITHIN ALL PR AS
PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
AND KOBE NINETEEN RESPONSE. THE
STATE INVESTED IN BUILDING
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING ARTNERSHIPS WITH
TRUSTED MESSENGERS ON THE GROUND
THIS OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WILL ARE ON THE
FRONTLINES OF ALL ALL OF THIS
ISSUES. WHICH IS BANNED AND ALSO
ROBUST DATA TOOLS AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS. TO ENCOURAGE
CALIFORNIANS HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES. THE SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL YOU KNOW
I'M GOING FUNDING WOULD CREATE
THE NEW OFFICE OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS. THE MOUTHFUL I
KNOW. AND THAT WOULD BUILD UPON
THESE PRIOR EFFORTS BY
IDENTIFYING AND MANAGING THE
STATE'S HIGHEST PRIORITY PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND COMMUNITY OUTREACH
CAMPAIGNS. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE PROPOSED OFFICE
WOULD ONLY FOCUS ON THE STATE'S
HIGHEST PRIORITY PUBLIC
EDUCATION. AND COMMUNITY OCT
OUTREACH PROGRAMS THE OFFICE
WOULD FACILITATE CLOSE
COOPERATION ACROSS THE STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES TO
MAXIMIZE REACH AND IMPACT OF
RESOURCES IN COMMUNITIES WITH
THE HIGHEST HEALTH AND SOCIAL
INEQUITIES. PROVIDE GRANT
FUNDING TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER PARTNER
OPENS ORGANIZATIONS AND CREATE A
FEEDBACK LOOP OF COMMUNICATION
AND INSIDE BETWEEN. COMMUNITIES
PARTNERS AND RELEVANT
DEPARTMENTS THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE WOULD ALLOW FOR A
CONSISTENT AND TARGETED
COMMUNICATION AND BUILD A STRONG
NETWORK OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND PARTNERS. THE
OFFICE WOULD LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE
EFFICIENCIES THAT ADDRESS
BARRIERS FACED BY CBO'S
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT IS WITHOUT REDUCING.
INVESTING IN EFFORTS LIKE THIS
ARE IN THIS I BELIEVE IN THE
STATE'S INTEREST AS IT WOULD
PROVIDE. OPPORTUNITIES TO
IMPROVE. SERVICE DELIVERY
INCLUDING TO CALL OF HARD. TO
REACH CA. ANY NEIGHBOR GREATER.
ANIMAL EQUITABLE UP ON LOCATION
STATE STAY SPENDING. LASTLY AS
THE STATE CONTINUES ITS
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY THE
PROPOSAL OFFICE OF OFFICE. WOULD
PROVIDE A KEY TRANSIT IN BAD
EQUITY WITHIN OUR APPROACH TO
TRUE AND MEANINGFUL COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE LEARN THROUGH CALLED IT
AND A LOT OF THE CRISIS THAT WE
GO THROUGH AS WELL AS EVERY TEN
YEARS OR ON THE CENSUS. IS WE
REACH OUT TO HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF CBO'S ORGANIZED I'M
GET THE WORK DONE RESPOND
EFFICIENTLY AND THEN WE DISBURSE
AND THEN WE RECREATE DOT AGAIN
AND AGAIN THIS IS AN IDEA THAT
IS NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT
OTHER STATES TRYING TO LEARN.
FROM HOW RESPONSIVE THEY HAVE
BEEN THROUGH THE CORPORATE
PROCESS HOW GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
RESPONSIVE IN A SHORT TIME AND
THIS IS AN IDEA TO
INSTITUTIONALIZED DOC KIND OF
FUNCTION THAT HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE. IN MY OPINION SO THAT
IS THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF THIS
PROPOSED OFFICE AND- WILL BE
HAPPY STATE QUESTIONS. I ALSO
HAVE. WITH ME- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL LADEN BANGKOK'S LABORED
TO BILLS BEING EXTREMELY ENGAGED
A STATEWIDE- WITHIN A PR AROUND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENTS WHO IS
VERY. KNOWLEDGEABLE AROUND- THIS
ISSUES THAT WILL BE HAPPY. TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS NOW. THIS
MEMBER HAVE ANY. AT THIS MOMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO FINANCE
AN L. A. O. CENTER CABALLERO.
YES THIS PARTICULAR- ISSUE ITEM
REFERENCES LESSONS LEARNED COULD
YOU- PROVIDE TO THE COMMITTEE
WHAT THE LESSONS LEARNED MORE
FROM THE CENSUS AND THAT COVERED
NINETEEN COMMUNICATION CAMPAIGNS
WE SPEND A LOT OF MONEY ON BOTH
OF THOSE CAMPAIGNS. AND I THINK
IT WOULD BE HELP FOR HELPFUL FOR
US TO KNOW A LOT OF THE OF THE
CAMPAIGNS ARE CONTRACTS THAT WE
PAY. TO BIG ORGANIZATIONS TO
BIG- ENTITIES AND- AND WE SHOULD
WE SHOULD KNOW WHAT'S WORKING
AND WHAT'S NOT AND WHAT WE MIGHT
WANT TO DO DIFFERENTLY. BECAUSE
I THINK SOME OF THE PIECES OF
THE CAMPAIGN WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
VERY GOOD IN OTHERS WERE JUST
THE DISMAL FAILURE I'D LIKE TO
SEE WITH THAT WITH THAT. THANK
YOU THAT'S ALL I HAVE. THANK YOU
AND I WILL- BUT THERE ARE LOTS
OF LESSONS LEARNED AND I HAVE
OTHER STUFF WHO HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN THE CARPET- RESPONSE
SO I'M GONNA COLD ARE THERE ANY
BOARD LANE TO RESPOND TO THAT
SPECIFIC QUESTION WHICH IS.
REALLY IMPORTANT. I NEAR YOU ON
THE CALL. THE NEW. I'M NOT SURE
SHE'S ON THE CALL I'M NOW LIST A
FEW OF THEM- ONE OF THE LESSONS
LEARNED NOT ONLY AGAIN THE STATE
BUT OTHER SOME LEARN THROUGH THE
CORPORATE PROCESSES TO FALL FROM
ONE FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE- I. WE HAVE BEEN
VERY I DROUGHT AND QUICK IN OUR
RESPONSE- THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF
LESSONS LEARNED AROUND ENGAGING
CBO'S- IN THE KIND OF RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED THE KINDS OF
ENGAGEMENTS THAT THEY NEED AND
WE WANT TO EXTEND OUT- AS A
PERMANENT WAY OF SUPPORTING THAT
PROCESS ALASKA LIMBONG CLOAKS
ROCKETRY THE RESPOND
SPECIFICALLY AND SOME SPECIFIC
LESSONS LEARNED THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. LENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU DIRECTOR AND- THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION AND IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND A COUPLE
OF THE LESSONS THAT WE LEARNED
THROUGH THE EIGHTEENTH THE
CENSUS THE VACCINE A NUMBER OF
OTHER. COMMUNITY OUTREACH
CAMPAIGNS IS AROUND THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING TRUSTED
PARTNERS TO HELP CARRY THE
MESSAGE THE STATE FROM THE STAGE
TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AND YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT
THE INFORMATION IS CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE. AND ABLE TO YEAR TO
COME FROM A MESSENGER WHO IS
TRUST AND HAS AN EXISTING
RELATIONSHIP IS MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE WHEN ESPECIALLY WHEN-
CONVEYING CRITICAL IN IN
INFORMATION THAT IS ALSO TIME
BOUND. UP THE OTHER THING THE
OTHER BIG LESSON I THINK THAT WE
NEED NOTED FROM THESE PROCESS
USES THE COMPLEXITY AND TO BE
ABLE TO GET ACCESS TO COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF STANDING UP AS
STRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO. VIAD
RESOURCE INTO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IS COMPLEX. AND IT
IS IT IS CHALLENGING AS TIME
CONSUMING. AND SO BEING ABLE TO
HAVE A STRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
AWARD- EITHER GRANTS OR
CONTRACTS TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THESE RESOURCES. IS A PROCESS
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING TO
FIND WAYS TO MAKE THAT MORE
EFFICIENT. AND THEN- I THINK THE
OTHER THING TOO IS THAT THERE WE
NEED TO LEARN THAT THE VIEW THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE CBO'S. AS
IT RELATES TO BEING ABLE TO-
HAVE ONGOING STAFFING TO BE ABLE
TO- PUT IN PLACE IS THE SYSTEMS
THE STRUCTURES THE ONGOING
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE ADEQUATE SUPPORT AND
INFORMATION TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF BEING ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT MESSAGING IS RECEIVED
AND COMMUNICATED IN A TIMELY AND
EFFICIENT FASHION. YOUR. SO ALL
OF THAT'S VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ALL OF THAT'S VERY
HOW HELPFUL BUT WE ALSO SPENT. I
RECOLLECT CORRECTLY- ON THE
CENSUS CLOSE TO FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADVERTISING AND I'M
I'M WONDERIG IF WE HAVE LESSONS
LEARNED THERE ABOUT WHAT. WHAT
WORKED AND WHAT DIDN'T AND WHAT
WHAT KINDS OF COMMUNITIES AND I.
I APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE RIGHT
NOW I DIDN'T EXPECT IT RIGHT NOW
I JUST WANTED IT GENERALLY AND
THAT. FOR A WEST WE LOOK AT THIS
PARTICULAR- ISSUE ITEM FOR THE
FUTURE- I HAD. HE AND NUMBER OF
THE MAYORS A VERY SMALL
COMMUNITIES. PREPARE A LESSONS
LEARNED BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT
PART OF THE CODE ROLLOUT OR THE
DISCUSSION WAS ALL DONE FROM THE
COUNTY LEVEL WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND I'M I'M
WONDERING IF MAYBE GETTING THAT
LIST WOULD BE HELPFUL. TO THE
ANALYSIS AS WELL JUST BECAUSE-
IN TURN IN TERMS OF TRUSTED ME
MESSAGE MESSENGER'S MAYORS ARE
GENERALLY WELL LIKED BY THEIR
COMMUNITY THAT'S WHY THEY EEP.
BECOMING MAYORS AND IT IT MAY
MAKE MAKE MAY MAKE SENSE TO HAVE
THEIR LIST IN ADDITION SO THAT
WORK. WE'RE PUTTING IT TOGETHER
WITH THEM WITH WHAT YOU'VE
LEARNED. AS WELL. THAT THAT'S
KIND OF THE REASON FOR MY
QUESTION IS- I BELIEVE AND I MAY
BE TOTALLY WRONG THAT SOME OF
THE MESSAGING THAT WE DID-
THROUGH THE MEDIA DIDN'T GET TO
WHERE IT NEEDED TO GO AND SO HOW
DO WE DO A BETTER JOB NEXT TIME
WE SPEND A LOT OF MONEY ON THE
CENSUS AND- AND SOME OF THE
UPTAKE WAS PRETTY SLOW- SO. WHAT
DID WE LEARN FROM THAT I GUESS
IS MY QUESTION. SO I AM THANK
YOU I DON'T EXPECT MORE MORE
DISCUSSION ON THIS WE HAVE A LOT
MORE ITEMS BUT I WANTED I DID
WANT TO. BRING UP THE ISSUE-
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THERE WERE
. WELL THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT I THINK WE NEED TO BE
ON. A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAILED
IN TERMS OF- HOW WE HOW WE DO IT
THINGS DIFFERENTLY. IF WE HAVE A
NATURAL DISASTER HOW DO WE
COMMUNICATE WITH. WITH THAT THE
COMPLEX. RESIDENTS THAT WE HAVE
IN THE STATE. LIMAY IF I MAY
FOLLOW UP ON ON THAT YOU KNOW
ART OR WITNESSES SPOKEN ABOUT WE
SHOULD BE MORE EFFICIENT AND
THERE SHOULD BE STRUCTURES. WELL
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM WHERE
DO WE LEARN WHERE AND HOW WE
SHOULD BECOME MORE EFFICIENT AND
THAT'S WHY THE SPECIFICITY OF
CENTER COPIERS QUESTION IS
IMPORTANT. WHAT DID WE LEARN
FROM WHAT THE CENSUS WHAT OTHER
SOURCES HAVE WE LEARNED FROM.
WE'RE NOT GETTING THE ANSWERS TO
THAT. AND THEN WE'RE BEING ASKED
TO INVEST MORE SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES. IN THE FUTURE AND A
YEAR FROM NOW WILL BE HERE IN
THE SAME DIALOGUE. THE SAME
ANSWERS THE SAME QUESTIONS THAT
WE'RE ASKING HERE TODAY. WE WILL
NOT HAVE ANYMORE MEASURABLES
ANYMORE EVIDENCE. OF THE NEAT.
LET ME FOCUS ON ONE SPECIFIC
POINT. AND ASK THIS. ALLEGE
ANALYST. THIS TALKS ABOUT THE-
NEW LAW OFFICE OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS. HOW IS THAT ANY
DIFFERENT THIS NEW DEPARTMENT
FROM WHAT THEY- AND I APOLOGIZE
I DON'T EVEN REMEMBER WHAT THE
CURRENT NAME OF IT IS THE OFFICE
OF INFORMATION. TECHNOLOGY IS
SUPPOSED TO DO. IT WAS ONE
CALLED ALL RIGHT IT WAS A
ACRONYM AND THEN IT BECAME BILL
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT IT IS NOW
BUT- HOW. IS THAT AGENCY THAT
DEPARTMENT. WHICH IS A FAIRLY
LARGE DEPARTMENT NOW. CAN THEY
BE DOING THIS KIND OF. SCRUTINY
RESEARCH AND REPORTING ANALYST
WHY DO WE HAVE TO START A NEW
OFFICE. HI THIS IS BRIAN WHETHER
FORD WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND- I THINK
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION ABOUT
WHERE- IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
CREATING- SOME SORT OF ENTITY
THAT WOULD- ADDRESS THE
COMMUNICATIONS- NEEDS THAT. THAT
THAT WHERE WHERE THAT'S LOCATED
IS I THINK SOMETHING THAT I'M
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED. YOU KNOW
WITH REGARD TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S MOST APPROPRIATE- PLACE
FOR THIS- WE EIGHT. YOU KNOW WE
WOULD SUGGEST AS AN ALTERNATIVE
PROP THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY WHICH- HAS EXPERIENCE
WITH PUBLIC OUTREACH HAVING
OVERSEEN THE TWENTY TWENTY
SENSES. ARE RECOVERED AND- ALSO
WE NOTE THAT YOU KNOW GO ABOUT
SUCH KIND OF A BROAD MISSION
THAT'S NOT FOCUSED ON ANY
PARTICULAR PUBLIC POLICY AREA
AND MAYBE NEED MORE NEUTRAL
ABOUT WHICH TOPICS TO FOCUS ON
THAN OTHER ALTERNATIVES. BUT I
DON'T KNOW DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR
YOUR QUESTION CENTER. WELL NO
SONG IT'S CLEAR AS MUD BUT IT
COVERS THE GROUND. I THINK WE
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE- SO LET'S
KEEP THAT DIALOGUE GOING. AND I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT- WE
WILL WE WILL BE HAPPY TO GET
BACK TO YOU WITH MORE DETAILS
BUT THOSE THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM BEFORE WE GO ON TO THE-
NEXT ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. CENTER
FOR ME WE HAD SOME PREPARED
REMARKS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL MORE
GENERALLY WE HAVE SOME OTHER
ISSUES FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
BESIDES JUST WHERE THE OFFICE
WOULD BE LOCATED I WAS ONE IF I
BY PRESENTERS NOW. LET'S GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO WE DO THINK
FIFTY GOVERNOR HAS IDENTIFIED A
LEGITIMATE NEED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL BECAUSE THE STATE. DOES
HAVE A NUMBER OF DISPARATE
COMMUNICATIONS AND COMMUNITY
OUTREACH EFFORTS IN ITS- MISSION
TO THE CENSUS WHICH ON. YOU
KNOW- CENTER COUPLE YEAR
MENTIONED HAD SOME. POSITIVE
OUTCOMES AND MAYBE SOME LESSONS
TO BE LEARNT THERE'S ALSO FOR
EXAMPLE THE CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS OUT REACH- THAT'S BEING
ADMINISTERED BY THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD IN THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES DEPARTMENT. AND
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH THAT SHOWED
THAT IT- MIGHT HAVE- GRAYSON
WARINESS BUT ALSO DIDN'T LEAD TO
ANY INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT-
CREDITS BEING CLAIMED. SO THERE
ARE- POTENTIALLY OPPORTUNITIES
THAT COULD BE GAINED BY
DESIGNATING A SINGLE ENTITY TO
FOCUS ON THE CENTRALISING
EXPERTISE MAINTAINING
RELATIONSHIPS AND HOPEFULLY
CREATE EFFICIENCIES BUT WE'RE
NOT SURE THIS PROPOSAL ADDRESSES
THIS NEED. AS IT'S STILL
CONCEPTUAL DOESN'T PROVIDE THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE AMOUNT OF
REQUESTS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
DETAILS. SO WHAT SHOULD YOU
AGREE THAT THE CONCEPT HAS MERIT
ONE OF THE CONSIDERATIONS WE
WANT TO RAISE TO YOU- IS THAT.
WE'RE SKEPTICAL THAT ONGOING
FUNDING AMOUNT REQUEST WOULD BE
NECESSARY RATHER WE WOULD
SUGGEST ONLY PROVIDING
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AND THEN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR OTHER SPECIFIC
INITIATIVES IS NEEDED. AND THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE FUNDING TO- AND
THE FOCUS TO ADJUST OVER TIME
WITH THE STATE'S NEEDS AND THE
LAST ON ISSUE THAT I WANTED TO
RAISE- REGARDS THE DESIGNATION
OR DETERMINATION OF. WHAT THE
STATE'S HIGHEST PRIORITY
COMMUNICATIONS ARE IN ANY GIVEN
YEAR THE PROPOSAL REPEAL THE
SAYS IT WOULD FOCUS ON THOSE BUT
WE'RE NOT SURE HOW THAT WOULD BE
DETERMINED IN MEETING COULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE. SOME SAY IN SETTING THOSE
PRIORITIES. THANK YOU. THAT IS
VERY HELPFUL. AND THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD CALL PUTTING SOME MEAT ON
THE BONE. AND SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND ALLOWING THE
LEGISLATURE BETTER INFORMATION
TO BASE WHAT WE WOULD DO IN THE
FUTURE- SIR HOW WOULD YOU
COMMENT ON THE- INQUIRY ABOUT
THE DUPLICATION OR THE- ROLE OF
THE OFFICE OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY THE CITY THESE ISSUES
HERE COULDN'T THOSE BE RESOLVED
IN THAT DEPARTMENT- I I'M SORRY
I'M NOT. SURE THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY BE THE
APPROPRIATE SPACE BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGIES CONTROL AGENCY FOR
OTHER STATE AGENCIES SO IT MAY
BE APPROPRIATE AND OVERSEEING A
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT RELATED TO
MAINTAINING. NETWORKS ARE
CONTEXT I'M NOT SURE IT WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE LOCATION TO
ADMINISTER GRANTS- TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OR DIRECTLY
BE INVOLVED IN MARKETING AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS. WELL
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH PROBABLY BUT GENERALLY
COULD PERFORM THAT FUNCTION. BUT
I JUST HARPER NO TRUST OR
CONFIDENCE WITHOUT SOME KIND OF
BENCHMARK SOME MEASURABLE SOME
SPECIFIC THINGS THAT HAVE GOT TO
BE DELIVERED. AND WE HAVE NOT
GOTTEN REALLY DIRECT ANSWERS TO
OUR QUESTIONS THEY'VE BEEN SORT
OF GENERAL. I BELIEVE THE
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THE LEARNING
THE LESSONS OF THE CENSUS OF
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. WHAT HAVE
WE LEARNED AND HOW WOULD THAT IT
AND THAT'S ONLY ONE PART OF THE
OTHER PART IS HOW THAN THAT
WOULD APPLY TO WHAT THIS CALL
NEW IDEA. WILL BRING TO US. OKAY
ANYTHING ELSE ON MY BONUS POINTS
FOR. WE DO- WE DO SUGGEST THAT
THAT THINKING ABOUT HOW YOU
WOULD EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THESE ACTIVITIES WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO DEVELOP AT THE BE
KIDDING LAKE WHILE WE ARE
DEVELOPING THIS PROPOSAL WHETHER
IT'S THE ADMINISTRATION
PREFERABLY WITH THE- INPUT OF
THE LEGISLATURE- WE ALSO KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF PRACTICAL
CONSIDERATIONS RELATED TO
TRANSFERRING CURRENT OUTRAGE
RESPONSIBILITIES- THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT A PUBLIC HEALTH IS
CURRENTLY ADMINISTRATING A LOT
OF THE- THE VACCINE AND A COVERT
RELATED OUT REACH. AND THERE
HAVEN'T BEEN ANY DETAILS
PROVIDED ABOUT HOW STAFF OR
RESOURCES- WOULD BE TRANSFERRED
AND THEN GOING FORWARD HOW THIS
OFFICE WOULD COORDINATE ITS OUR
COMMUNICATIONS- ACTIVITIES WITH-
WILL IN THIS CASE THE CALIFORNIA
BERMAN A PUBLIC HEALTH AND
POSSIBLY DEPENDING ON THE
COMMUNICATIONS PARTIES OTHER
DEPARTMENTS IN THE FUTURE. THE
FOR KERR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WOULD YOU HAVE ANY OBSERVATIONS
HERE. YEAH KEVIN CLARK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
BOB I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
RELEASE DEMONSTRATION RELEASED
FOR THE BILL LANGUAGE YESTERDAY
THAT CLEARLY ARTICULATES THE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OF THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE THE OPPOSITION'S
DAY. AND IN THAT TAPE IN THAT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- WE ALSO
INCLUDES- INDICATORS FIVE KEY
INDICATORS THAT WOULD HELP
ASSESS WHAT TYPE OF- OUR
MESSAGING CAMPAIGNS WOULD BE-
CONSIDERED UNDERNEATH IT THE
OFFICE IS ABOUT INCLUDES AYE ALL
THAT YOU WENT OUT OF HIS HIGH
LEVEL. AND INCLUDES- FOCUSED ON
EQUITY FOCUS ON CAMPAIGNS HAVE
DATA DRIVEN TO POINT TO THAT
AND- CANDIES ARE ACTIONABLE.
THEY'RE ALSO GOING TO LOOKING AT
RISK SEVERITY AND URGENCY OF THE
CAMPAIGN THE NEEDS OF DRESSING.
AND ALSO THE IMPACT- AND HOW THE
CAMPAIGN MAYBE CROSS
DEPARTMENTAL ACROSS AGENCY.
WOULD ALSO JUST POINT OUT THAT-
PR'S CHARGE IS REALLY DOING
MINISTER AND BLACK COMPLEX AND
CROSS DEPARTMENTAL COORDINATE
EFFORTS. AND SO YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES BELIEVE
THAT- COORDINATING STRATEGIC
OVERSIGHT OF PUBLIC AWARENESS
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
CAMPAIGNS FOR THE ADVOCACY OF
THE STATEWIDE CAMPAIGNS. WELL
THEN IT'S OBVIOUS DEPARTMENT
FINANCES STILL. DOING WORK ON
THIS BUT- MY OBSERVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHY DIDN'T
YOU BRING THIS INFORMATION
FORWARD LITTLE SURE AS WE'VE
INQUIRED HERE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
INSTRUCTED. WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
YOU JUST DONE YESTERDAY. AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
GOING TO BRING ANY OF THAT
INFORMATION TO US IN THE FUTURE
AS WE PROCEED WITH THE UDGET
PROCESS WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
VOTING ON SOME OF THIS TODAY.
BUT WHAT WE NEED THAT
INFORMATION FORTHCOMING YES
INDEED THE BUDGET IS A DYNAMIC
PROCESS AND CHANGES AS IT GOES.
BUT AT LEAST IN MY PART I'M
EXPRESSING SOME FRUSTRATION. AT
HOW HARD IT IS TO DRAG
INFORMATION OUT OF AGENCIES
PEARL. IN OUR BUDGET HEARINGS.
AND THE UNDERSTAND THE SENATE
HAS EMBARKED ON A KIND OF A-
DIFFERENT DIRECTION HERE THE
LAST FEW YEARS. AND THAT IS
ACCEPTING EIGHT OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY. OF THE SENATE.
OVERSIGHT AND ONE OF THE BEST
PLACES FOR THAT TO OCCUR BE HERE
IN THE BUDGET. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM ANY OF THE FOLKS
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE. AT THE
HEART OF IRAQ I. PLEASE SIR YES
I JUST READ AGAIN YOU'RE ASKING
VERY POINTED QUESTIONS THAT
THOSE ARE REALLY ALL OF THEM ARE
IMPORTANCE WILL ADD MORE
INFORMATION BUT I JUST WANT TO
SAY IN ADDITION TO WHAT KEVIN
FROM BUREAU OUT OF STATED WE
HAVE SENT A DETAILED LIST OF
LESSONS LEARNED FROM CORBETT
NINETEEN AND OTHER SENSORS IN
OUR BCP REPORT. THAT YOU HAVE
NOT ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT BUT WE WILL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION THE
IDEA IS BOTH LESSONS LEARNED
WILL HELP INFORM THE STRUCTURE
THE EFFICIENCY AND THE FOCUS OF
THIS NEW PROPOSED OFFICE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR GIVING US A
REFERENCE POINT. AND THAT WILL
HELPFUL WE WILL NOT THAT. IN A
GOOD STAFF WILL BE LOOKING INTO
THAT TOO AND BRING IT TO OUR
ATTENTION- WITH. BOTH OF OUR
STAFF TO. BE VERY ATTENTIVE TO
BE HELPFUL HERE. ARE WE PREPARE
THEM TO MOVE ON. ALL RIGHT. TO
OUR NEXT THEN SECTION WOULD BE
THE PARTNERSHIP AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS. THE VOLUNTEERS
PROPOSAL. THE VOLUNTEERS
PROPOSAL. YES SIR SENATOR I WILL
INTRODUCE OUR CHIEF SERVICES
OFFICER JOSH FRIDAY FROM LOKI
ARCS WALK YOU THROUGH THE
PROPOSAL- FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE CORPS STATE SERVICES
PROGRAM THE NEXT ITEM JOSH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DIRECTOR-
THANK YOU SENATORS YOUR TIME SEE
YOU ALL MY NAME IS JOSH FRIDAY
AND HE SERVICE OFFICERS AND- IN
OVERSEA CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
THIS YEAR WE HAVE THREE BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
ONE IS THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
ACTION COURT TO THE NEIGHBOR TO
NEIGHBOR PROGRAM AND THREE
FOSTER GRANDPARENTS AND SENIOR
COMPANIONS PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE ACTION CORPS
BUDGET PROPOSAL SEEKS TO MAKE ON
GOING THE LIMITED TERM
INVESTMENT OF THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN A
PROGRAMMATIC CLIMATE PROGRAMS
FOR A TOTAL ONGOING REQUEST OF
FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION THE
INITIAL APPROPRIATION RECEIVED
IN THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROVIDED
ONGOING STAFF BUT ONLY THREE
YEARS OF FUNDING FOR PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION AND WE ARE NOW
REQUESTING THIS PROGRAMMATIC
FUNDING BE ON GOING TO ENSURE
THE SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM AS YOU MAY
KNOW LEVERAGES FEDERAL
AMERICORPS FUNDING- AND WHILE
THIS PROGRAM IS STILL IN ITS
EARLY STAGES THE INTEREST HAS
BEEN SUBSTANTIAL WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE INTEREST IN
POSITIONS. THAT WERE ABLE TO
FILL AND WE'VE ALSO. THE PROGRAM
IT'S RECENTLY BEEN WRITTEN ABOUT
AS A MODEL FOR A POTENTIAL
NATIONAL CRIME RECORDS. IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THIS
PROGRAM WILL BE CRITICAL TO
MEETING ALL OF OUR STATES
CLIMATE GOAS. WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM TO DATE
AS HAS BEEN REQUESTED- AND I
LOOK FORWARD VERY MUCH TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU ALL.
ON THIS SPECIFIC ITEM. FOR THE
NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THE FOSTER
GRANDPARENTS AND SENIOR
COMPANIONS BUDGET PROPOSALS THEY
BUILD ON THE SUCCESS THAT WE
HAVE HAD DURING THE PANDEMIC TO
ACTIVATE CALIFORNIANS TO SERVING
TO TACKLE SOME OF OUR GREATEST
CHALLENGES. AND DURING THE DAY
DANCE DURING THIS PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS LAUNCHED
THE NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR
PROGRAM. WHICH PREVIOUSLY LETTER
WHICH LEVERAGED PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED DISASTER FUNDING AND
NOW WE'RE REQUESTING TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING TO
MAINTAIN THIS PROGRAM. AND ALSO
TO BUILD IT OUT THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE. FOR FUTURE
DISASTERS AND TO MEET OTHER
STATE PRIORITIES THE NEIGHBOR TO
NEIGHBOR PROGRAM BECAUSE OUR
NEIGHBORS TO BE THE FIRST IN A
LINE OF SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS TO
CONNECT NEIGHBORS. TO TAKE
ACTION AND TO SUPPORT EACH
OTHER. AFTER THE PROGRAM
LAUNCHED MY OFFICE MET A COUPLE
FROM INDIO- WHICH I LOVED IT DID
QUICKLY TELL YOU ABOUT THE
BECAUSE THEY LEFT A LASTING
IMPRESSION ON ALL OF US AND I
THINK ALSO DEMONSTRATES. ONE WAY
THAT THIS PROGRAM IS GONNA HAVE
AN IMPORTANT IMPACT FOR OUR
STATE. WE MET JEAN WHO IS EIGHTY
FIVE YEARS OLD AT THE TIME AND
THEN WITH A NINETY TWO YEAR OLD
WORLD WAR TWO THE NAVY VETERANS-
AND I HAPPEN TO HAVE A SPECIAL
AFFINITY TO NAVY VETERANS. WITH
THE CONGESTIVE HEART FAILURE-
AND HE HAD BEEN IN SELF
QUARANTINE FOR WEEKS AND
STARTING TO RUN OUT OF SUPPLIES
AND FOOD- AND BECAUSE OF THE
TIMING OF IT THEY WERE NOT ABLE
TO FIND A LOCAL STORE TO DELIVER
TO THEIR HOME. AND SO JEAN
REACHED OUT THROUGH THE NEIGHBOR
TO NEIGHBOR PROGRAM THAT WE HAD
LAUNCHED TO CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS IN BECAUSE OF THIS
PROGRAM. WE WERE ABLE TO
ALTERNATELY ARRANGED THE
DELIVERY OF MILK. AEGS TOILET
PAPER AND GOODS THAT WERE. NOT
TO THE COUPLE. SO THROUGH THIS
pPANDEMIC AS WELL AS OTHER
DISASTERS WE HAVE LEARNED THE
CRITICAL NATURE OF EMPOWERING
NEIGHBORS TO HELP EACH OTHER.
AND WE ARE VERY EXCITED TO BUILD
THIS OUT ACROSS THE STATE IN THE
COMING YEARS. THE FOSTER
GRANDPARENTS AND SENIOR
COMPANIONS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS A
ONE TIME IF I LIVE TO EXPAND
THESE ALREADY EXISTING
AMERICORPS PROGRAMS. AND AS YOU
MAY ALL KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS OPERATES THE LARGEST
AMERICORPS PORTFOLIO IN THE
COUNTRY. THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL WOULD ESTABLISH A
PASSED THROUGH A TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COMPETITIVELY
APPLY FOR IN OUR WARD GRANT'S
ASSOCIATED. WITH THESE TWO
PROGRAMS. AND WHILE THE TYPICAL
DEMOGRAPHICS THE CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS ARE AMERICORPS
MEMBERS. ARE GENERALLY
INDIVIDUALS AGES EIGHTEEN TO
THIRTY THIS INVESTMENT BUILDS ON
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS LEADERSHIP
AND SERVICE AND COMPREHENSIVE
EXPAND SERVICE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OLDER CALIFORNIANS. I'M ALSO-
JOINED TODAY BY MY COLLEAGUE IN
THE CHAVEZ AND WE LOOK FOR TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ON THESE PROPOSALS THANK
YOU. IF YOU'RE CALLING COMMENT
HERE AT THIS POINT- JUST BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS I THINK
MOSTLY AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
BUT A LOT OF JUNK AND IF NEED
BE. OKAY MANY OF OUR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. ON A REQUIRE
THIS. ISSUE LONG TO. ALL RIGHT-
pWE WE'VE HAD A LOT OF SUCCESSION
MANY PROGRAMS WITH THE
VOLUNTEERS FOR SURE. AND I THINK
YOU LATER AT LEAST A- REASONABLE
ARGUMENT- HOW THIS COULD. BE
JUSTIFIED IN EXPANDING. BUT LET
ME ASK YOU THIS QUESTION WERE WE
TO PROCEED WITH THIS. BUDGET
PROPOSAL. WHAT WOULD YOU BE
BRINGING FORWARD TO THE
COMMITTEE NEXT YEAR. TO
ASCERTAIN THE PROGRESS AND
SUCCESS OF NOT JUST IN GENERAL
THE VERY SPECIFIC. WHAT WOULD BE
THE BENCHMARKS OF SUCCESS THAT
WE COULD MEASURE NEXT YEAR TO
SEE IF THIS MONEY WAS WELL SPENT
. THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION- ALSO ALLOW MY
COLLEAGUES ANTHONY TRAVIS IT TO
JUMP IN- TO HELP ANSWER BUT I
THINK- WE ARE VERY- WE THINK
IT'S- VERY IMPORTANT- TO HAVE
SPECIFIC METRICS AND OUTCOMES
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH ABOUT WHAT. OUR
VOLUNTEERS ARE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT
THEY'RE HAVING- AND WE HOPE WITH
YOUR SUPPORT THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO COME BACK AND HAVE VERY
SPECIFIC NUMBERS OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE WE ENGAGING THE
SERVICE PROGRAMS HOW MANY OLDER
CALIFORNIANS. HAVE PARTICIPATED
BECAUSE OF THIS PROGRAM IN BEING
ABLE TO SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND FEEL CONNECTED TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES HOW MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A STATEMENT AND A
SCHOLARSHIP FOR COLLEGE. AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A REAL
CAREER PATH BECAUSE WE'VE
INVESTED IN THE SERVICE AND
VOLUNTEER OPPORTUNITIES HOW MANY
NEIGHBORS VERY SPECIFICALLY DID
WE ENGAGED IN RETRAIN DID WE
EMPOWER AS LEADERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
AND BE RESILIENT. IN A DISASTER
SITUATION THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
NUMBERS- AND SPECIFIC DATA THAT
WE. FULLY EXPECT AND HOPE TO
BRING BACK TO YOU NEXT YEAR.
VERY SAYS SECTOR. SIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR NOW LET ME ASK
THIS QUESTION. HOW WOOD WE
LEGISLATORS WHO REPRESENT
DIVERSE AREAS AND I MEAN DIVERSE
AS IN RURAL URBAN AND SUBURBAN.
COMMUNITIES HOW CAN WE BE
ASSURED THAT THESE. AVENUES WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO THEM. TAKE FROM
MODOC COUNTY TO FRESNO COUNTY TO
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY HOW WILL
THAT BE AVAILABLE AVAIL THEM TO
MOTIVATE AND SUPPORT THEIR. I
THINK I AM ONE IS TO KNOW THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE STATEWIDE AND
OUR FOCUS WILL BE STATEWIDE BUT
I THINK IT TURNS CAN COME FROM
THE FACT THAT WE ARE OFFICE
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THIS ROLE HAS
PRIORITIZE INVESTING IN THE
COMMUNITIES YOU JUST MENTIONED
ON MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
REACHING OUT A BROAD. SWATH OF
CALIFORNIA SO FOR EXAMPLE- THE
LEGISLATURE INVESTED AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS A COUPLE YEARS AGO- IT
TO INCREASE AMERICORPS
POSITIONS- WITHIN MY OFFICE- FOR
US TO CREATE MORE POSITIONS FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
START. BECAUSE OF THAT
INVESTMENT WE WERE ABLE TO
CREATE A BRAND NEW INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM IN BUTTE COUNTY TO
SUPPORT THE RECOVERY OF THE- OF
THE COMMUNITY FROM THE PARADISE
FIRE IT'S A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE OF
HOW WE ARE ABLE TO USE SERVICE
POSITIONS- TO BRING RESOURCES TO
THAT COMMUNITY. IN ORDER TO HELP
THEM THE EXAMPLE I GAVE OF THE
NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR PROGRAM
WITHIN IN GENE COMES FROM INDIO
CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY LIVED IN A
RURAL AREA- WHERE THEY DIDN'T-
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO A TO
US CLOSE SUPERMARKETS ARE CLOSE
BY- AND OTHER RESOURCES THAT
WERE CLOSE BY BECAUSE OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE INVEST IN
THE PROGRAM THAT WE CREATED. WE
WERE ABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES- IN A VERY REAL WAY.
WELL YOU'RE SPEAKING THE HEART
THERE RELATED TO WHAT YOU HAD
DONE UP FOR PARADISE AND YOU
KNOW I'M NOT. OF THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT ASSISTANCE
THAT COMMUNITY AS AN IS REBUILT
. AND I WILL ATTEST TO THE
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS. OF THAT
REBUILD. I'VE ALWAYS SAID AND I
GIVE YOU THEN SOME CREDIT TO.
FOR THIS SUCCESS THE STORY OF
THE- A NICE FIRE WILL NOT BE.
THE FIRE. OR EVEN THE DEATH. THE
LETTERS ALL TRAGIC BUT THE REAL
STORY IS HOW THE COMMUNITY CAME
BACK. AND THAT'S WHERE YOU FIT
INTO THE PICTURE. ANY OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE ADDITIONAL
INQUIRIES REGARDING THE
VOLUNTEER PROPOSALS. AND THEN WE
WOULD GO ON TO THE TRIBAL
AFFAIRS OFFICE ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE THANK YOU VICE CHAIR- ISSUE
NUMBER NINE- THE TRIBAL AFFAIRS
OFFICE THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION I REQUEST
THAT THE NET ZERO TRANSFER OF
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE FUND
ONGOING. AND FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ON GOING AND THREE
POSITIONS FROM THE COMMISSION TO
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF TRIBAL
AFFAIRS WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. SENATE ZERO TRANSFER OF
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS THROUGH- PHYSICAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH SUPPORT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA TRUTH AND
HEALING COUNCIL. ALSO TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON GOING
AND TWO POSITIONS TO COMPLY WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS OF A. B. TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY SIX A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN- TWO SEVENTY FIVE I'M
SORRY. AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE AND A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
GRAVES PROTECTION AND REYES. A
THREE YEAR RADIATION ACT. THE
PROPOSAL BUILDS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO
PRIORITIZE AND ALIBIED
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WITH TRIBAL NATIONS
AND WILL HELP THE STATE'S TO
BETTER DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
POLICY AND INITIATIVES IMPORTANT
TO TRIBAL NATIONS. AND IT WILL
HAVE- I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT MY CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- SCOTT MORGAN-
AVAILABLE ACCOUNTS OR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HOP THANK YOU
. DO ANY OF THE COLLEAGUES HAVE
ANY COURTSHIP ENQUIRIES ON THIS
ISSUE. WE HAVE NOT- WHEN I MAKE
SURE I DIDN'T HAVE SOMETHING ON
THE SHELF. PARDON WHO DID- SHOOT
ME I CAN'T I DON'T HAVE THAT
DISCOUNT OF L. A. L. YOU HAD
YOUR HAND UP ON THE ON THE
MONITOR SO PLEASE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO WAIT IN. I'M JUST WANTED TO
KNOW THAT WE HAVE NO CONCERNS ON
THIS PROPOSAL. OKAY WELL THANK
YOU ARE STANDING THERE. TO THE
FOR. WITH US AND FOR US. NEXT
ITEM WOULD BE THE ISSUE NUMBER
TEN. LEGISLATIVE AUGMENTATION.
SIR ALL GO BACK AND ALSO OKAY
ARE STE LEGISLATIVE TEAM SERVES
AN IMPORTANT FUNCTION AS- WE ALL
KNOW TO ENSURE THAT PROPOSED
LEGISLATIONS ARE RAISED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND ADDRESSED
WITH BILL AUTHORS AND SPONSORS
AND ENGAGING OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
LEGISLATURES AS WELL. AS
LEGISLATIVE STAFF THE DISUNITY
ENGAGES WITH LEGS THAT HAVE
OFFICES TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET
PRIORITIES THE LEGISLATIVE TEAM
HAVE ASKED WITH AN INCREASING
NUMBER OF DUTIES ON A VARIETY OF
HIGH PRIORITIES OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS AND WITH NEW BUDGETS
AND WHILE THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINSTRATION'S EXPANSION OF
PROGRAMS OUT OPR HAS BEEN SWIFT
THE STOPPING FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
WORK HAS NOT BE KEPT UP PACE TO
FULLY SUPPORT APPEARANCE VARIOUS
BUDGETARY OBLIGATIONS AND BUDGET
PROGRAMS OVER THE PAST. FEW
YEARS TO WILL REQUESTING ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWO POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
ONGOING TO SUPPORT THE GROWING
AMOUNT OF LEGISLATIVE WORKLOAD
ACROSS OPS BUDGET PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL STC CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS AND OPR STATE
PLANNING AND POLICY- AT PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE OFFICE. AND WILL
BE AVAILABLE. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. OKAY
THANK YOU MUCH NOW WITH TO HEAR
FROM THE OF. HI KEVIN CLARK WITH
BERMAN OF FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
AND NOW L. A. O. LEGISLATIVE IN
A BRAND WHETHER FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THIS PROPOSAL SUPPORTED ON A
WORK WITH FACES. THANK YOU FOR
THAT I'D LIKE TO BRING IT BACK
TO DISCUSSION FROM THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE VICE CHAIR.
WELL IT IT MAY I ASK
SPECIFICALLY WHAT IS THAT
WORKLOAD BASIS THAN THAT. IF YOU
ACTUALLY DID THE INCORPORATION
OF THE NUMBER OF LEGISLATIVE.
INQUIRIES AND RESPONSES. IS THAT
WHERE YOU GET IN GAME THAT THE
OBSERVATION THAT RESPONSE THAT
DATA. SENATOR THAT IS CORRECT-
WE REQUESTED BACK UP FOR ON THE
PROPOSAL AND THEY PROVIDED.
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
NUMBER OF BILLS THAT THEY ARE
ANALYZING THAT THE OFFICES IN
THE PAST ANALYZE EVERY YEAR AND-
THEIR WORKLOAD HAS OF THE OFFICE
OVERALL- THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
HAVE. BEEN INCREASED OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. AND SO IT'S
REASONABLE TO EXPECT THAT FROM A
NUMBER OF THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE
AND MANAGEMENT- RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE INCREASING THE POTENTIAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROB SENATOR
CABALLERO. I'M I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THIS I GUESS THE
COMMENT IS YOU KNOW THE MORE.
TASKS WE COME UP WITH- FROM THE
LEGISLATURE OR FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION I GUESS THERE
WOULD BE- YOU KNOW I NEED TO
HAVE MORE STAFFING POSITIONS BUT
I THINK IT ALWAYS GOES BACK TO.
HAVING THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN THE
RIGHT SEATS DOING THE RIGHT
WORK- TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS GET WHAT THEY NEED-
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THIS ONE OPEN. I SEE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN- THE UPDATE ON GOBIZ
SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF PROGRAM.
SO ARE WE READY ARE YOU READY
SAM. OKAY I BELIEVE WE HAVE
SOMEONE WE HAVE SOMEONE ELSE I'M
SORRY YES AFTERNOON CHAIR COM
LONGER THAT. CAROLYN GRAY HERE-
HELLO TO ALL OF YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY- I AM DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY TO REPORT
ON OUR RELIEF PROGRAMS I WILL BE
GETTING WITH AN UPDATE ON NET ON
THE SMALL BUSINESS COULD BE
NINETEEN RELIEF CRACKED PROGRAM.
ON THIS PROGRAM HAS RECEIVED A
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION GENERAL
FUND PLUS ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
IN FEDERAL FUNDS TO PROVIDE
RELIEF GRANTS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES BETWEEN FIVE THOUSAND
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THERE HAVE BEEN NINE
ROUNDS OF GRANTS WOULD TO BROWN
SPECIFICALLY DEDICATED TO
NONPROFIT CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
AS OF JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH THIS
YEAR THERE HAVE BEEN AT. THREE
HUNDRED TWELVE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE AWARDS
TOTALING THREE BILLION. FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION.
700-400-0800 EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS
AND- THE SENATE COMMITTEE WILL
RECEIVE A BREAKDOWN OF ALL THE
AWARDS IN EACH OF YOUR
INDIVIDUAL TESTS TAX I'M A AND
I'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT ROUND
NINE AWARDS ARE STILL BEING
MADE. AWARD STATING IS POSTED ON
ON OUR WEBSITE UNDER
PUBLICATIONS THERE ARE FEW
THINGS TO NOTE ABOUT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS. SEVENTY
SIX POINT 7% ON THAT AS THE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED TO
LOW TO MODERATE INCOME- I SMALL
BUSINESSES OF FIFTY FOUR POINT
9% HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED TO
MINORITY OWNED SMALL BUSINESSES
AND 53% HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED TO
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESS SAYS- SO.
THAT ME TO OUR- HOPE REALLY- PRO
WHICH IS THAT GROUP NICE IT GRAN
PROGRAM. HOW DOES PROGRAM APPROX
FOR MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
GRANTS AND TO K. MICRO
BUSINESSES AND IT IS TO BE
ADMINISTERED AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL- GRANTS IN THE AMOUNT OF
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS ARE BEING AWARDED TO
MICRO BUSINESS SAYS. THAT HAVE
LESS THAN FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN REVENUE AND LESS THAN FIVE
EMPLOYEES. ROUND ONE OF THIS
PROGRAM IS COMPLETE WITH TWENTY
SIX COUNTIES HAVING RECEIVED A
NOTICE OF INTENT TO AWARD.
TWENTY COUNTIES HAVE FULLY
EXECUTED CONTRACTS AND
REQUISITIONS HAVE BEEN DONE FOR
A TOTAL OF TWENTY SIX MILLION.
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED NINE DOLLARS AND
SIXTY SIX CENTS WE HAVE SIX
COUNTIES THAT ARE GOING THROUGH.
LOCAL APPROVAL PROCESS FOR A
TOTAL OF FOURTEEN MILLION
800-401-0001 HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
DOLLARS. ON TOTAL DOLLARS
COMMITTED IN THE FIRST ROUND OF
FORTY ONE MILLION. TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT DOLLARS. I GROUND
CHIU- THAT- R. F. P. I OPENED ON
JANUARY TWENTY SIX FOR COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS AND CONSORTIUMS OF
NONPROFITS TO APPLY ITS GRANT
MAKING AND FEES THAT WILL BE
OPEN UNTIL THE TENTH OF MARCH.
AND ROLLING AWARDS WILL BE MADE
FOR COUNTIES WHO APPLY. IN ROUND
SHE'LL. LAST AT PROGRAM AT FOR
HOPE IT RELIEF ARMED GROUP OF
PROGRAMS IS CALIFORNIA VENUES
CRAP. AS SAYS ON FEBRUARY EIGHT
YESTERDAY- FORTY AWARDS HAVE
BEEN MADE FOR A TOTAL OF SEVEN
MILLION. FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED FIVE
DOLLARS. I'M WE HAVE ANOTHER
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTEEN- A LIVE
VENUE CENTERS THAT WERE SELECTED
TO GO THROUGH THE VALIDATION AND
VERIFICATION PROCESS WHICH TAKES
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE DAYS ON
NOT ALL APPLICANTS AND WHO ARE
SELECTED WILL BE AWARDED THE
SELECTIONS ARE ON GOING. AND WE
ARE WORKING AT THE REAL I ANY
ISSUE RELATED TO NASCO SURNAMES
CODE SIX YEARS OLD- AS THAT MAY
HAVE OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE ENTITIES
TEAM TAKE AN ELIGIBLE I SAID WE
ARE WE ARE WORKING TO YEAR ON
GET. RESOLUTION TO THAT. ALL
OKAY. ON ON THOSE. OKAY GREAT
THANKS- I DON'T KNOW DOES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
ANYTHING THEY WANT TO SHARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TOMORROW JOHNSON
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU L. A- DO
YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
ASK. BRING WEATHERFORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE DO WE DO NOT HAVE ANYTHING
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VICE
CHAIR DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS OKAY SENATOR ROB.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST TWO
QUICK ONES. EMBASSY A CALIPH
YOU'VE CALIFORNIA VENUE GRANT-
MY NOTICE IT'S INDEPENDENT
VENUES LIVE EVENTS MINOR LEAGUE
SPORTS. HAS THERE BEEN ANY
CONSIDERATION TO. ADDING A
COMPONENT FOR. OUR MOVIE THEATER
OPERATIONS IN THE STATE- WHICH
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. I IN SOME
CASES PERHAPS TO THE SAME IF NOT
A GREATER EXTENT IS SOME OF THE-
VENUE LOCATIONS IDENTIFIED IN
THE CURRENT BUDGET- ACTION. WE
HAVE NOT HEARD SPECIFICALLY-
THAT FROM MOVIE THEATERS THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FRIEND THAT ON
ADVOCATES ARE REPRESENTING MANY
VENUES IN THAT SPACE AND- WE ARE
WORKING WITH THEM TO UNDERSTAND
FULLY AND COMPLETELY- WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS THEY WOULD THEY
WOULD HAVE FOR CHANGES. PERFECT
THAT'S OF. WE CAN ASK THE TO-
YOU ENGAGE WITH THAT PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE SOME ASSISTANCE- IF
APPROPRIATE THAT WE DO SO ONE
FINAL QUESTION ON THE- NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS GRANTS. IS THIS
GRANT THE PROGRAM AVAILABLE TO
NONPROFIT A PERFORMING ARTS
EDUCATIONAL ENTITIES IN OTHER
WORDS NON PROFITS THAT ARE
PERFORMING EDUCATION- AND
PERHAPS PERFORMANCE RELATED
EDUCATION IN THE PERFORMING ARTS
FIELD- YOU KNOW ALONE. ARE YOU I
THINK I WILL PULL IN- RALPH. WHO
HAS BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR ADVOCATES AND SEE
WHETHER OR NOT SHE WOULD HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD ON THAT. THANK
YOU. I SENATOR ROTH IT'S GOOD TO
SEE YOU MORRELL FARSI DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR GOV IS. GOING TO GO BACK
QUICKLY TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
THE THEATERS BUT CAN YOU REPEAT
YOUR LAST QUESTION IF YOU DON'T
MIND PLEASE RIGHT I WAS JUST
INTERESTED IN KNOWING WHETHER OR
LEARNING WHETHER OR NOT OF THIS
. PERFORMING ARTS GRANT PROGRAM
IS AVAILABLE TO NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS EDUCATIONAL
ENTITIES IN OTHER WORDS
PERFORMING ARTS ACADEMIES. OF
THAT PREPARED HAVE A PERFORMANCE
ASPECTTO THEM BUT ALSO AN
EDUCATIONAL ASPECT. I THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR ROTH AT
SO I HAVE TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT
THE STATUTE IT'S SOMETHING I CAN
LOOK AT MORE CAREFULLY TO SEE-
IF THE NOT FOR PROFIT PERFORMING
ARTS CENTERS WOULD WOULD BE
ELIGBLE I KNOW THAT THE PROGRAM
IS- IS RELATIVELY BROAD AND-
FLEXIBLE FOR NONPROFITS AND EVEN
FOR THOSE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE. A FISCAL SPONSORSHIP AND
MAY NOT HAVE THEIR OWN- FIVE OH
ONE C. THREE SO. YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTION I'M HAPPY TO GO BACK
AND WORK. ARE THE DIRECT OF
GREAT CAN. FOLLOW BACK UP WITH
YOU IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
RESPONSES AND WITH RESPECT TO
THE MOVIE THEATERS I JUST WANTED
TO CLARIFY HAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED. OUTRAGE FROM THE MOVIE
THEATERS HOWEVER WHEN IT WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE WE'RE NOT
EXACTLY SURE- WHAT ENDED UP IN
THE FINAL STATUTE OR WHY BUT WE
YOU KNOW WE'RE AS A DIRECTOR
GRACE SAID IT WE ARE.
CONTINUOUSLY OPEN AT HEARING
FROM STAKEHOLDERS ON ANYTHING
THAT MAY BE APPROPRIATE. GREAT
AND THE REASON I ASK MY QUESTION
ABOUT THE PERFORMING ARTS
GRANTS. IS THE RELATES TO THE
STAFF COMMENT THAT- ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION IN FUNDING REMAINS ON
ALLOCATED IN THAT PARTICULAR
CATEGORY AND SO THINKING THAT
GIVEN THE- THE DEFICIT IN
PERFORMING ARTS EDUCATION- AND
RELATED IN OUR PUBLIC. PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM PERFORMING ARTS
ACADEMIES HAVE SPROUTED UP OF
ACROSS OUR STATE THAT BEFORE
THAT PROVIDE BOTH THE EDUCATION
COMPONENT. AND PERFORMING
PERFORMANCE IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND I- I'M JUST WAS
JUST WONDERING IF THE FUNDING
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR THOSE BUT
THANK YOU FOR TAKING A LOOK AT
THAT FOR ME. I'M TO. YOU SENATOR
. HI DAD TO- IS A DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
REMAINING IS FROM THE SMALL
BUSINESS CODE RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM WE HAD TO- TO SPECIFIC
BROWN'S OR NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS AND OVER TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS A DOT AND YOUR
REMAINING SECOND FIVE- WE DO
HAVE THE NONPROFIT PERFORMING
ARTS GRANTS- THAT WHICH WE ARE
STANDING UP RIGHT NOW WHAT. WE
HAD TO WE RELEASED A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL I'M TRYING TO ELIGIBLE
GRANT MAKING ENTITIES BACK IN
JANUARY JANUARY TWENTY FIRST AND
THE APPLICATIONS WERE ACCEPTED
THREE YESTERDAY AND WE'RE
SCHEDULED TO REVIEW PROPOSALS
AND MAKE AN AWARD FOR GRANT
MAKING FOR THAT PROGRAM NEXT
WEEK AND THAT WILL- BE FOR NON
PROFIT- PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS TO ENCOURAGE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. CENTER IS
BRINGING. ACTED TO THE GREAT THE
GRANTS WILL BE NEED TO TWO FIVE
TO. AND SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO BE AWARDED ON A FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE BASIS AND ON
THAT DEPENDENT ON- TAXABLE
REVENUES AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
WILL INFLUENCE. OUT WHICH LEVEL
OF GRANTS AND THE APPLICANTS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE AND THAT WAS
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET CORRECT
DIRECTOR. THAT APPROPRIATIONS
YES LAST SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
YESTERDAY FIFTY FOOT INSIDE WAS
NOT AWARE OF THAT I'M SURE MANY
IN MY COMMUNITY WERE PROBABLY
NOT PERHAPS IF OUR REVENUES
CONTINUE TO BE ROBUST THIS YEAR
BEYOND OF OUR CURRENT
EXPECTATIONS. PERHAPS WE COULD
GIVE SOME CONSIDERATION TO-
OPENING EIGHT HEARING SOME MONEY
AUGMENTING SOME MONEY IN THAT
PROGRAM AND THEN RE OPENING THE
APPLICATION PROCESS JUST X.
SUGGESTION. ALL MS GRAY ARE YOU
WITH US. YES I AM OKAY YOU FROZE
I'M SORRY I DID I'M NOT A D.
INSTEAD OF ON AT LEAST SAYING WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE THAT AND
PUT HER TO SAY I NORMALLY LOOK
LIKE THAT AFTER TEN HOURS IN
THIS. THANK YOU MA'AM. IF I MAY. IS THERE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I WON A SECOND WHAT MY
GOOD FRIEND- CENTER RUSTED ABOUT
THE PERFORMANCE OR EDUCATIONAL
ASPECT AND ALSO THE MOVIE MOVIE
THEATERS THAT WAS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD. IN REGARDS TO
THE MICRO UP SO LET ME JUST SAY
THAT- I THINK THAT THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE REALLY- ROLLED OUT
VERY SMOOTHLY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THAT
HAS BEEN DONE ON THE ON THE-
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS- AND I
I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME
OF THE BUSINESSES THAT. THEY
HAVE RECEIVED THOSE GRANTS AND
THEY'RE VERY THANKFUL AND THE
PROCESS WAS- WAS WELL ORGANIZED
SO CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT IN
REGARDS TO THE MICRO GRANTS- YOU
MENTIONED THAT TWENTY SIX COUNTY
SUPPLIED. AND THAT TWENTY. IF I
UNDERSTOOD CORRECTLY. MY NOTES
ARE AND ARE NOT AS GOOD AS IT
COULD BE- THERE ARE THERE WERE
TWENTY THAT WE'RE THAT RECEIVE
THE CONTRACT- THERE'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES YOU HVE A LIST
OF THE COUNTIES THAT. THAT DID
NOT APPLY IN IS THERE DO WE KNOW
WHY THEY DIDN'T APPLY- I'M I'M-
CURIOUS ABOUT THAT. SO JUST TO
RECAP THAT THEY DATA WE RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS FOR- FROM TWENTY
SIX COUNTIES IN ROUND ONE- THAT
WE ISSUED A NOTICE OF INTENT TO
ALL TWENTY SIX EACH ONE HAS
THEIR OWN IT AND YOU KNOW LOCAL
APPROVAL PROCESS THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH FOR I'M RIGHT ENTERING
INTO THE CONTRACT SO WE FULLY
EXPECT AND THAT WE WILL HAVE
TWENTY SIX- WE'RE JUST NOTING%
THAT ONLY TWENTY HAVE BEEN FULLY
EXECUTED AT THIS TIME I AM HAPPY
TO PROVIDE IT AND A FULL LIST.
OF THOSE THAT HAVE NOT YET- UP
OUTSIDE BUT WE DO HAS AN
UPCOMING WEAPON AREN'T AND OF
THOSE DOES- REMAINING JAPANESE-
OF THE AT THE FIFTY EIGHT WE
HAVE A BALLOT FIFTEEN OF THOSE
REPRESENTATIVE VIA REGISTRATION
AND OUR WEB IN OUR- THAT THAT IS
NOT COMING OUR REGARDING THEIR
ROUND TWO U. R. F. P. AND I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU
GOT LAST. IF I MAY FOLLOW UP OF
. LOOKING GREAT THE THEATERS
HAVE COME UP HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE FROM EACH MEMBER WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT A THROUGH
THE THREE OF US AT LEAST- HAVE
RAISED ISSUES ABOUT THIS AND
THAT WOULD MEAN INDICATED THAT
WE'VE SOMEHOW BEEN A BEEN
AFFECTED IN THE DISTRICT YOU
REPRESENT. I CAN CERTAINLY
ATTEST IN MY CASE IT'S BECAUSE
OF THE FIRES. BUT IT IT ND'S
LEADERS ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT IN
SMALL COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S OF
LOBBYIST REASONS WHY. BUT LOSING
THEM THEN- IT'S QUITE A SET BACK
FOR THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEIR
VENUES NOT JUST FOR THE PICTURE
SHOWS BUT FOR OTHER ACTIVITIES
AS WELL UP WOOD COULD YOU BE
ABLE TO GET TO OUR OFFICES IT
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE. YOU'RE
SORT OF WORKING ON IT BUT I'M
NOT SURE TO WHAT DEGREE AND WHAT
MANNER OF WHO ARE THE KEY
CONTACT PERSONS SO OUR OFFICES
CAN WORK WITH YOU THROUGH YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE THEATERS THAT WE
REPRESENT THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED COULD YOU. GET THAT
INFORMATION TO US. YES SIR WE
AYE I WILL- WORK WITH HIGHER AND
- BLACKSTOCK SAID TO PULL THAT
TOGETHER FOR YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE NEXT
WOULD BE THE CALIFORNIA TOURISM
RECOVERY FUNDING. FINANCE. TIME
NEW DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND ON
OUR JOHNSON DEPARTMENT FINANCE-
I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE- MISTER
RYAN BACKER FROM DE UM. AND
THERE'S A CALIFORNIA THAT IS
ABLE TO- PRESENT THIS- IS
PROPOSAL. PLEASE RYAN GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SENATOR THE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- PROPOSED
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR-
CONTINUED TOURISM MARKETING FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
ADMINISTERED BY VISIT CALIFORNIA
NO WE ARE CURRENTLY OPERATING-
OF ABOUT 33% DECLINE IN OVERALL-
COLLECTIONS ARE TYPICALLY
PRIVATELY FUNDED BY BUSINESSES
IN THE STATE OF THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT REVENUE HAD HAS BEEN
IMPACTED- BY VIA DOWNTURN IN
TOURISM DUE TO THE IN THE MAKE
IN THE TOURISM MARKETING OF HIS
CALIFORNIA IS DOING. IS GETTING
THE RECOVERY AS ENDEMIC
RESTRICTIONS ARE BEING LISTED-
ANY QUESTIONS. MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS. NINE BILLION YEAH THE
JOURNALIST. BRING WHETHER FORD
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA WE
FIND THAT THERE'S A CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING RESOURCES SUPPLEMENTED
BY THE STATE'S NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRIBUTION IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET SHOULD
SUPPORT ADVERTISING SPENDING
SOMEWHAT ABOVE PRE PANDEMIC
LEVELS WITHOUT ADDITIONAL STATE
FUNDS BUT WE DON'T DISPUTE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSESSMENT OF THE
IMPACT OF COVETED ON THE TOURISM
INDUSTRY OR ITS DECLINE IN
REVENUES AND WE COMMEND IT'S A
CALIFORNIA FOR PRUDENTLY
REDUCING SPENDING ON ADVERTISING
AT THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC.
AND WE NOTE THAT- THAT THE
AMOUNT THAT IT HAS SHOULD BE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO RESTORE
SPENDING WHILE IT'S ASSESSMENT
REVENUES RECOVER TO THE EXTENT
THAT ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING
WOULD ALLOW THE ORGANIZATION TO
SPEND SIGNIFICANTLY MORE ON
ADVERTISING THAN IT DID BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC WE JUST HAVE TO BE
INCREMENTAL BENEFIT OF THIS
ADDITIONAL- ADVERTISING IS
UNCLEAR. THANK YOU FOR THAT NOW
WE'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP FOR
DISCUSSION WITH THE COMMITTEE.
VICE CHAIR NIELSEN. SENATOR
CABALLERO. SENATOR ROCK. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ISSUE. NUMBER THIRTEEN
IMMIGRATION INTEGRATION AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. IS IT
STILL MISS GRAY. WITH SENATOR
HELLO THIS IS EMILY DECIDE FROM
A DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND TRADE
TEAM AND I WOULD BE I'M GLAD TO
TALK ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL. WILL HIT. THANK YOU
SENATOR- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS EMILY
DECIDED DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND TRADE
TEAM AT GO BIDS. GENERATIONS OF
IMMIGRANTS FROM ACROSS THE GLOBE
HAVE CHANGED SHAPE TO
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND
PROGRESS. TODAY IMMIGRANTS
COMPRISE 27% OF THE POPULATION
WELL HALF OF ALL CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE AT LEAST ONE
IMMIGRANT PARENTS. IT'S WHETHER
THEY ARRIVE TO SEEK SAFETY OR
OPPORTUNITY HAVE BEEN INTEGRAL
TO CALIFORNIA'S IDENTITY AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH FOR MANY
GENERATIONS. AND CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A NATIONAL LEADER IN
DEVELOPING POLICIES AND PROGRAMS
AIM TO SUPPORT OUR STATE'S
DIVERSE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
PARTICULARLY TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. AND TO
ENHANCE CRITICAL LABOR AND
WORKFORCE PROTECTIONS. EXPANDING
THIS EXPERTISE WITHIN WITHIN THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
INTERNATIONAL PORTFOLIO AND GO
THIS IS THE NEXT CHAPTER TO
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS TO ADVANCE
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION AND
EQUITY. WITH THAT IN MIND WE ARE
REQUESTING ELEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH SERVES TWO
PRIMARY FUNCTIONS. FIRST IT AIMS
TO ADDRESS THE GAP IN RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT STATEWIDE CONVENING
IN COORDINATION FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT IS
POPULATION FOCUSED ACROSS THE
PORTFOLIOS OF OUR STATE AGENCY
PARTNERS. ASIAN EVENTS RECENT
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED THE BENEFITS
AND IMPORTANCE OF COORDINATION
ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT TO
SUPPORT EFFECTIVE RESPONSES. THE
INTERNATIONAL FAIRS AND TRADE
TEAM ALREADY PLAYS A UNIQUE ROLE
AS A CONVENER INCLUDING ON
ISSUES RELATED TO THE CALIFORNIA
MEXICO BORDER AND OTHER
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS. AND IS
WELL POSITIONED TO SUPPORT
STATEWIDE IN INTEGRATION
COORDINATION AN IMMIGRANT
EXPERTISE ACROSS GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. SECOND
THIS PROPOSAL BUILDS ON THE
STATE INVESTMENT IN ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. IT DOES THIS
THROUGH ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO HELP CITIES
AND COUNTY SEAT AND THE PLAY
BEST PRACTICES IN PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. FOR IMMIGRANT
ENTREPRENEURS AND BUSINESS
OWNERS CREATING ACCESSIBLE IN
TAYLOR BUSINESS START GUIDES IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES AND SUPPORTS
BUSINESS GROWTH AND RESILIENCY
THROUGH EXPORT TRAINING AND
CROSS BORDER ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. THANK YOU TAMARA JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOTHING TO
ADD. THANK YOU- L. A. L. YES
BRIAN WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE BUT
WE JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
STATE SUPPORTS MANY EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
MENTORING OPPORTUNITIES AND
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO UNDERSERVED
BUSINESSES AND ENTREPRENEURS.
FROM MANY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS
HOW THIS PROPOSAL WOULD HELP
ADDRESS CHALLENGES SPECIFICALLY
FACED BY IMMIGRANT BUSINESSES-
THAT ARE NOT ADDRESSED BY THESE
EXISTING PROGRAMS IS UNCLEAR-
THAT'S IT SOME SOME COMPONENTS
THIS PACKAGE SUCH AS TRANSLATING
ASSISTANCE FOR ENTREPRENEURS
INTO LANGUAGES OTHER THAN
ENGLISH COULD HAVE MERIT. MANY
OF THE STATE'S RESIDENTS HAVE A
GREATER FLUENCY IN A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH AND-
TRANSLATING STATE RESOURCES INTO
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH
WOULD HAVE MERIT- AND THAT
EXTENDS TO- MANY MANY MANY MANY
RESIDENTS NOT JUST DEMOCRATS AND
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO COULD
CONSIDER WHETHER THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND OTHER
STATE AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES TO BUSINESSES. SHOULD
MAKE MORE OF THEIR FORMS AN
INFORMATIONAL MATERIALS
AVAILABLE MAKE WHICH IS OTHER
THAN ENGLISH- WE HAVE A POST
THAT WAS JUST PUBLISHED ON OUR
WEBSITE- I'M SORRY. REGARDING GO
BIZ WE HAVE A PERSONALLY
PUBLISHED ON A WEBSITE LATER
THIS WEEK THAT EXPANDS ON SOME
OF OUR SPECIFIC CONCERNS
REGARDING THE EIGHT POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM. SO
I WENT UP INTO THOSE NOW UNLESS
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR. THE IRAQ.
ANNA CABALLERO. I YOU KNOW I
ACTUALLY HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
THIS. I YOU KNOW I CALL ME CRAZY
BUT I THINK THAT- FOLKS THAT ARE
TRYING TO START A BUSINESSES
FROM OUR IMMIGRANT POPULATION
PROBABLY NEED MORE THAN JUST
START UP GUIDES- AND SO I AM
HOPING THAT THERE CAN BE MORE
DETAIL AROUND THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I- THAT ACTUALLY
STRUCK ME OVER THE WEEKEND WHEN
I WAS HOME IN MY DISTRICT I WAS
IN. DOWNTOWN LA AT AN EVENT
THERE WERE- LOTS OF PEOPLE- LOTS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES RIGHT
VENDORS- OUT ON THE STREET-
SELLING THEIR WARES IN PRODUCTS
AND I ENDED UP HAVING A
DISCUSSION. WITH SOMEONE- WITH A
CONSTITUENT ABOUT- SPECIFICALLY-
LATINO ENTREPRENEURS- WHO HAVE
SMALL MOM AND POP START UPS- AND
HAVE TO WHETHER CARTELS- AND HOW
IT REALLY PLAYS A ROLE IN HOW
MUCH THEY'RE ABLE TO SELL WHAT
THEY HAVE TO SELL I MEAN HOW
THEY'RE ABLE TO SURVIVE. AND SO
YOU KNOW I WOULD HOPE AND I DOES
HAVE TO BE SPECIFIC TO THIS BUT
THERE CAN BE SOME REAL
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
PROTECT- AND SUPPORT- MEMBERS OF
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIESTHAT
ARE INTERESTED IN HAVING
BUSINESSES AND STARTING THEM
THAT ARE TRYING TO DO IT WITH
SUPPORTS THAT PREVENT THEM FROM
HAVING TO DEAL WITH- PREDATORY-
ENTITIES- THAT ARE REALLY ARE
OUT TO HARM THEM. I WAS TRYING
TO BE VERY NICE TO SAY THAT
CARTELS PREY ON LOTS OF
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS- AND SO
HOPEFULLY THERE CAN BE SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE CAN USE
THESE KINDS OF SUPPORT SOME
FUNDING TO HELP THEM AT PROTECT
GET FEEL PROTECTED OR HAVE SOME
PROTECTION FROM THOSE GROUPS- I
KNOW YOU LIKE HANA. SENATOR I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO RESPOND- SO I
THINK PART OF WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING COULD COULD CERTAINLY
COME INTO PLAY WITH THE- ONE
TIME LOCAL GRANTS THAT WE HOPE
TO DEPLOY- IN SPEAKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THAT- DSS WHO-
TO PLAY GRANTS TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND JURISDICTIONS
FOR LEGAL AID AND SERVICES FOR
IMMIGRANTS- I THINK THIS COULD
BE A GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR- THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT WE HOPE
TO DEPLOY FUNDING TO CRAFT
PROGRAMS THAT MIGHT DO EXACTLY
THAT. AND COORDINATE WITH LEGAL
SERVICES- WHERE THERE ARE
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT ON
ON THE LEGAL SIDE SO COORDINATED
EFFORTS AND PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO CRAFT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ARE GOOD
PROVIDE SPECIFICS SUPPORT TO
THEIR ENTREPRENEURS IS ONE AREA
WHERE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS- THAT THE PROBLEM THAT
YOU'RE SPEAKING TO. THANK YOU
YES THE STREET VENDORS MOSTLY.
I'M SO. I'M GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE FOURTEEN COMBATING
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT. LIKE TO
HEAR FROM GOBIZ IS IT STILL
EMILY. NO THERE'S NO MATTER NO
MADAM CHAIR CAROLYN GRAY
DIRECTOR ON CALLAWAY C. EIGHTY
NINE- SO AS PART OF A LARGER
PROPOSAL TARGETING RETAIL FAST
WE ARE REQUESTING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND RETAIL INDUSTRY
EXPERTS TO DEVELOP THIS PROGRAM
WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE PROGRAM
WOULD SIMPLY COMPENSATE SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR PROPERTY LOSSES
AS A RESULT CRIME AND WE ARE ON
THAT DEFINING THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES AS- BUSINESSES WITH
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE
OR LAST. AND WE HAVE DRAFT
LANGUAGE COMPLETED AND BELIEVE
WE ARE REALLY CLOSE TO HAVING
SOMETHING PUBLISHED. A THANK
YOU'S THAT'S MILLION OR NET. I
REQUEST OKAY- BLAME RESIDENTS
OKAY GREAT- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. MARK JOHNSON DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALEJO. BRIAN WHETHER FORD WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- THIS ITEM IS PART OF A
LARGER PUBLIC SAFETY PACKAGE IN
OUR ANALYSIS THE GOVERNOR SPOKE
PROPOSAL FOR ADDRESSING
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT INCLUDING
A MORE IN DEPTH ANALYSIS OF THE
SITE AND IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
OTHER ASSOCIATED PROPOSALS WILL
BE PUBLISHED IN A SEPARATE BRIEF
THAT'S FORTHCOMING HOPEFULLY
FAIRLY SOON. IT WITH REGARDS TO
THE SPECIFIC- ITEM THE GENDER
HIGHLIGHTS AND THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE'VE RAISED
ABOUT- TO SOME OF THE PRACTICAL
CONSIDERATIONS WITH IMPLEMENTING
A PROGRAM LIKE THIS. I'M
STEPPING BACK A LITTLE BIT I
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT POINT
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE AS IT
RELATES TO THIS PROPOSAL IS
pINDIVIDUAL COMPONENTS OF THE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT PACKAGE
SUCH AS THIS ONE ON YOU SHOULD
CONSIDER WHETHER THE GOAL OF
THIS PROPOSAL IN THIS CASE TO
PROVIDE COMPENSATION FOR SOME
VICTIMS OF. OF RETAIL THEFT- THE
WAY IT'S WRITTEN IN BUDGET
BUILDING WHICH ON IS WHETHER
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH YOUR
BROADER PUBLIC SAFETY GOALS. AND
THEN DEPENDING ON YOUR
PRIORITIES THERE MIGHT BE MORE
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES TO THIS
PROPOSAL. IN OUR FORTHCOMING
BRIEF WE WILL PROVIDE A
FRAMEWORK TO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE THINK THREE SCHOOLS
AND PROBABLY PROVIDE VARIOUS
ALTERNATIVES THAT EXPAND ON
EXISTING PROGRAMS. AND THAT ARE
BASED ON RESEARCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I'M GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
MISTER VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU
MANAGER. YOU KNOW THIS ISSUE IS
OF ENORMOUS MAGNITUDE. IT'S
PROBABLY BEEN MOST VISUAL BY THE
INVASIONS OF LARGE BUSINESS. BY
GANGS AND OTHERS WHO HAD SOUGHT
TO PROFIT. BUT IT IS
PARTICULARLY DEVASTATING. FOR A
SMALL BUSINESS WHO ALSO I'VE
SUFFERED. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ANALYSTS FURTHER DEVELOPMENT OF
THE IDEA AND TAKEN IN CONTEXT OF
AN OVERALL MEANS OF ADDRESSING
THIS PROBLEM. SIMPLY RECOMPENSE
AND BUSINESSES SMALL OR EVEN
LARGE FOR THE LOSSES IS NOT AN
ANSWER. FOR A SMALL BUSINESS IT
MIGHT KEEP THEM ALIVE AND WELL
FOR OF TIME. BUT THE BIGGER
ISSUE STATUTORILY MUST BE
ADDRESSED AND DEALT WITH. AND IN
TERMS OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. IN
TERMS OF SENTENCING IN TERMS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES. THIS
IS A HUGE ISSUE. AND IT IS A
PRODUCT. MARJORIE A VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE. AND BOTH OF THE
LEGISLATURE. SO AS WE THE
LEGISLATURE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WE'VE GOT TO TAKE OF THE
COMPREHENSIVE MULTI FACETED
APPROACH. THE STOPPING. THIS
GREAT TRAVESTY THAT IS INFESTED
OUR COUNTRY THANK YOU MANAGER
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR SENATOR
CAFIERO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
I WANT TO A DEGREE- WITH SENATOR
NIELSEN I THINK THE- I'M I WANT
TO LOOK AT THE REPORT THANK YOU
TO THE L. A. O. FOR FOR DOING
THAT REPORT- I THINK WE'RE ALL
AWARE OF THE ISSUE- I'D HAVE
LAUGHED THE LARGER EFFECTIVE
RETAIL. BECAUSE OF THE SMASH AND
GRAB- ISSUES THAT ARE OF HAVE
POPPED UP. GET REALLY GIVE US
THE VISUAL OF HOW AWFUL AND HOW
DANGEROUS- THESE- THESE
ORGANIZED EFFORTS AT AT STEALING
OUR BUT I HAVE TO AGREE THAT I'M
NOT SURE WHO THAT COMPENSATING
FOR LOSSES IS THE SOLUTION I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT. HOW WE
CAN HELP BOB LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO SET UP THE SECURITY THEY NEED
AROUND THEIR RETAIL AREAS- AND-
AND LOOK AT IT THAT LOOK. LOOK
TO SEE IF THERE'S A WAY FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO BE PARTNERS WITH.
WITH OUR- OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO SET UP SECURITY
SYSTEM SO. I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE REPORT I'M NOT SURE THIS
IS THE ANSWER BUT- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THE DISCUSSION
IS STARTING HERE NO QUESTION WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WE CAN SOLVE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR ROCK-
I YOU KNOW- I ACTUALLY THINK
IT'S- YOU KNOW ADMIRABLE BUT
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT YOU KNOW
HOW THE FUNDS WOULD GET
DISTRIBUTED AND ALSO HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEWILLINGNESS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES TO EVEN TRY
TO APPLY FOR THIS KIND OF
COMPENSATION BECAUSE YOU KNOW-
IT'S ONE THING AND I DON'T WANT
TO LIKE YOU KNOW USE CERTAIN
BUSINESSES AS EXAMPLES BUT
LARGER COMPANIES THAT ARE PART
OF LIKE YOU KNOW SORT OF GLOBAL
CORPORATIONS WILL HAVE NO
PROBLEM TRYING TO ACCESS THIS
MONEY. BUT SMALLER BUSINESSES
MOM AND POP BUSINESSES WHO MAY
BE TARGETED YOU KNOW BY
ORGANIZED CRIME MAY FEEL
INTIMIDATED OR MIGHT BE HARASSED
YOU KNOW- IF THEY'RE SEEN TRYING
TO GET COMPENSATION ARE WORK
WITH THE GOVERNMENT YOU KNOW SO
I JUST THINK WE SHOULD BE
THINKING MORE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
IN REAL LIFE- FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SUFFERING.
FROM THIS KIND OF THEFT AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE THE MOST
HELPFUL TO THEM YOU KNOW- IT'S
GREAT TO COME UP WITH IDEAS BUT
I THINK WE NEED TO BE AS
PRACTICAL AS POSSIBLE WHEN WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP FOLKS. READ THANK
YOU I'M SO GLAD YOU KNOW I
ACTUALLY AM IN RULES- AND SO I
DID NOT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK ABOUT ITEM ELEVEN AND TWELVE
AND I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN DO
THAT BECAUSE IT IS GREAT YOU.
WERE TALKING ABOUT THOSE ITEMS.
SO WITH THE CAN JUST. AND WHY
OKAY COOL I JUST. THANK YOU
MISSOURI. SURE I COULD DO
WHATEVER NO. IT IS GREAT I
WANTED TO CLOSE WITH RON AND
ABOUT- MOVIES A FACT LAST YEAR
THERE WERE NUMBER OF STAY COLD
THAT RAISED ISSUE AND MO IN THE-
AND SO I KNOW- THE YOU'RE OFF
SAID YOU HAD HEARD SO I LIKE I
SAID I'M CO SIGNING WITH THE
GOOD CENTER MENTIONED BECAUSE
THIS SHOULD BE PART OF A
DISCUSSION THAT WE'RE HAVING AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. MANY OF THEM WERE ON THE
BRINK OF CLOSURE HAD TO FIND
OTHER THINGS THAT THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO DO IN ORDER TO STAY
OPEN- AND THEY HIRE LOTS OF
YOUNG FOLKS AND FOLKS FROM THE
COMMUNITY- YOU KNOW IN THOSE
POSITIONS AND SO I WANT TO
ELEVATE THAT THE OTHER THING IS.
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
IT REMAINS ON ALLOCATED- YOU
KNOW I WANT YOU WANT TO CONTINUE
TO INVESTIGATE THE WHY BEHIND
THAT I THINK THERE'S SOME
BARRIERS TO ENTRY I WANT TO GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE OF A CULTURAL
INSTITUTION THAT'S IN MY
DISTRICT THE MUSEUM OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN ART IT ALSO HAPPENS TO
BE LOCATED IN A DEPARTMENT STORE
THE DEPARTMENT STORE WAS CLOSED
BECAUSE THE CULPRIT. SO PEOPLE
COULDN'T GO TO THE MUSEUM. YOU
KNOW SO THAT'S LIKE A REAL LIFE
EXAMPLE OF LIKE. A IN A CULTURAL
INSTITUTION IN NEED OF SOME
HELP. BECAUSE THEY WERE SHOT
DOWN AND ACTUALLY THEY WERE NOT
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE- IN SOME OF
THE FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES AND
COMPENSATION OPPORTUNITIES. AND
SO. BUT BECAUSE OF THEIR UNIQUE.
SITUATION OF WHERE THEY WERE
LOCATED. IT ALSO THEY WERE SORT
OF CUT OFF SO. AS WE'RE LOOKING
AT WAYS TO GET THIS MONEY OUT
I'M JUST ASKING YOU TO AND NOT
YOU SPECIFICALLY BUT YOU IN
GENERAL TO BE A LITTLE MORE OPEN
MINDED. AND FLEXIBLE ABOUT SOME
OF THE NEEDS THAT MANY OF THESE
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS HAVE.
FASTA AND THEN TWELVE YES MANAGE
GO SORRY. GO AHEAD MS GRAY I WAS
JUST GOING TO SAY HI I WAS JUST
GOING TO SAY THAT WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE ADVOCATES ON
THIS ISSUE- TO HOPEFULLY COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION. GREAT AND THEN
FOR ITEM NUMBER TWELVE I HAD THE
GOOD FORTUNE OF. GOING TO A
VISIT CALIFORNIA- FILMING. AND
SUPER GREAT- AND THEY ALSO TALK
TO ME ABOUT HOW THEY GET THEIR
MONEY THAT THEY DID HAVE TO CUT
SPENDING THAT THEY ARE STILL
SORT OF COLLECTING FEES AND SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS WAS ASKED
BUT- THERE'S FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR-
AND SO HALF OF THIS NINETY FIVE
IS STILL LEFT SO JUST WANTED TO.
HEAR IT FROM MY OWN YEARS OF WHY
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE MONEY. BUT
MAYBE THAT WAS A MISS GRACE ITEM
. NO MA'AM THAT IS NOT MY ITEM.
WELL AS- I CAN I CAN MAYBE HELP
MATT COLLEAGUES FROM VISIT
CALIFORNIA HAS. OPT OFF I
BELIEVE ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GONNA
GET YOU WE CAN CERTAINLY GET YOU
THE RESPONSE TO THAT BUT IN
SHORT WHILE WHILE THE SPENDING
FOR THE ENTIRE NINETY FIVE IS
NOT COMPLETED YET WE ANTICIPATE
ALL HE'S BACK NEVER MIND I'M
GONNA GIVE HIM THE TIME. HOW ARE
HEARING WOULD YOU MIND READING
YOUR QUESTION. WHY ARE YOU
ASKING FOR FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WHEN THERE'S ON THE LEFT
FROM THE NINETY FIVE EVEN THOUGH
I ALSO WANT TO SAY I WENT TO A
SAID AND IT WAS REALLY FUN. BUT
NONETHELESS THIS IS CALIFORNIA'S
MONEY. ABSOLUTELY REALLY GOOD
QUESTION THANKS FOR ASKING IT-
THE PLAN WAS ALWAYS TO SPREAD
THE NINETY FIVE REALLY ACROSS
THE TWO MAJOR TRIP PLANNING
SEASONS ONE IN THE FALL AND ONE
IN THE SPRING SO. WE'RE ABOUT.
HALFWAY SPENT ABOUT FORTY FIVE
MILLION IN RIGHT NOW- THIS
SPRING. SAID AND THAT'LL
ACTUALLY START- THIS COMING
SUNDAY- YOU'LL SEE A BIG
CAMPAIGN LAUNCHED- THE RUN ALL
THE WAY INTO MAY AND JUNE- AND
THAT WILL- DEPLETE THE REMAINDER
OF THE NINETY FIVE MILLION. WELL
THAT WAS THE ONE I SAW BEING
FILMED BUT NOW THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO OPEN UP. FECAL WILL
PROBABLY INCREASE. YOU SEE WHERE
I'M GOING WITH MY QUESTION YES
IT'S ANOTHER REALLY GOOD QUITE.
A BIT THE REVENUE IS COLLECTED A
YEAR IN ARREARS SO JUST LIKE YOU
AND I'M HERE INCOME TAXES- IN
APRIL OUR OUR INCOME FROM THE
PREVIOUS TWELVE MONTHS- THE-
TOURISM FEE IS ASSESSED IN A
SIMILAR WAY SO BUSINESSES ARE
PAYING RIGHT NOW- ALIGNMENT-
REVENUE- FROM THAT THE DARKEST
DAYS THE PANDEMIC- AND SO WE'RE
NOT REALLY GOING TO BE BACK TO
WHOLE OUR PROJECTIONS ON THAT
THAT. ASSESSMENT REVENUE INTEL-
ARE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE. I
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK.
FATMAN CABALLERO HAS A QUESTION-
YOU DONT BECAUSE- GOOD QUESTIONS
ARE. THANK YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN. GOBIZ GO
AHEAD. WAS IT AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
OUT OF TELECOM BUT I NEED IT
THAT SENIOR DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
KOBE IS- THE SUPPLY CHAIN
DISRUPTION IS A STATE WIDE AND
NATIONAL ISSUE CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO THREE OF THE LARGEST
CARGO PORTS IN THE COUNTRY OUR
TWO LARGEST PORTS LEN LONG BEACH
HANDLE APPROXIMATELY 40% OF
IMPORTS AND 30% OF THE NATION'S
EXPORT. OUR COURTS ARE
EXPERIENCING MAJOR DISTRIBUTION
CHALLENGES SUCH AS OVERCROWDING
OF CONTAINERS AT PORT TERMINALS
SHORTAGE OF EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
JOCKEYS IN CONTAINERS AND
HISTORIC AKHADA CARGO VESSELS
THAT EAGER WAITING FOR BIRTH
SPACE NOW IN ADDITION TRUCK
DRIVERS HAVE BASED ON CERTAIN
KEY INCLUDING A LACK OF DETAIL
CARGO CONTAINER PICKUP SCHEDULES
VESSEL DELAYS CANCELLATIONS AND
UNCLEAR DELIVERY DESTINATIONS
CORRECT BROWN OPERATORS HAVE
ALSO BEEN IMPACTED BY UNCERTAIN
CARGO INFORMATION DETAILS. NOW
THESE MAJOR SUPPLY CHAIN
PROBLEMS ARE HINDERING THE
MOVEMENT OF GOODS LEADING TO
INCREASED. FOR CONSUMERS AND
BUSINESSES AND CREATING NEGATIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT NOW TO THE
AND OPENS IS REQUESTING THIRTY
MILLION FOR OPERATIONAL AND
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS AT THE PORT
TO ENABLE EFFICIENT CARGO
MOVEMENT REDUCE CONGESTION AND
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE
CARGO VOLUME BY PROMOTING AND
BUILDING SUPPLY CHAIN
EFFICIENCIES A LACK OF A
CENTRALIZED DATA SYSTEM HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO MUCH OF THE
CONFUSION OUTLINED AT THE CHANCE
TO THE OPERATOR HI-LO'S. AND IN
ORDER TO ENABLE REAL TIME
SITUATIONAL UPDATE TO INCREASE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN CARRIERS
TRUCKERS OFTEN MY SHIPMENT
ROUTES ALLEN ANY ONE HAND OFF
AND DATA AND ASSESSMENTS ARE ONE
OF THE AREAS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT VERY CLOSELY SO WE MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HAPPY ANSWER
ANY QUESTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NOW. WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MERSHON'S
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO COME AT
THIS. NOW LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE
A. O. BRAIN WITH A LETTER AND
ALL OFFICE- THIS PROPOSAL. IS
CHALLENGING FOR US TO ABOUT- ITS
MERITS BECAUSE IT HAD DIDN'T
PROVIDE WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED.
LIAM ANY INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
WOULD BE USED FOR- THEY
DISCUSSED WAS- USING THE FUNDING
TO HELP TO IMPROVE DATA
INTEROPERABLE IT- AMONG THE
PORTS THE RAILROADS THE OCEAN
CARRIERS DRING TERM TERMINAL
OPERATORS AND RAILROADS- SO. IF
THAT IS THE FINAL PROPOSAL WOULD
RAISE TWO CONCERNS THE FIRST IS
WHETHER KOBE IS WOULD BE THE
MOST APPROPRIATE AGENCY TO
ADMINISTER THE GRANT PROGRAM AND
THE SECOND WOULD BE WHETHER. IT
IS APPROPRIATE TO USE STATE
FUNDING TO IMPROVE
COMMUNICATIONS AND DATA SYSTEMS
FOR THESE PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
COMPANIES- AS THEY SHOULD ALL
HAVE SUFFICIENT PRIVATE
INCENTIVES TO ADOPT- ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING DID
INTERRUPT ABILITY BUT- WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO LEARNING.
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL AS IT DEVELOPS. SOUNDS
GOOD NOW I'M GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. MISTER VICE
CHAIR. WELL I HAVE TO OBSERVE
THAT THIS. THIS TO ME TO BE A
EFFORT BY THE ADMINISTRATION TO
SAY THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT THE PORTS. WHICH REALLY
WON'T AMOUNT TO MUCH OF ANYTHING
. WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE PORCH
IS A MACRO ISSUE OF GREAT
MAGNITUDE GREAT DETRIMENT TO THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY. AND PROTECT
THE ECONOMY OF CERTAIN AREAS
STRICTLY THOSE WHERE THE PORCH.
ARE LOCATED AND HE IT'S ALMOST
LAUGHABLE TO SAY THE
ADMINISTRATION THINKS THAT
THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING
CONSTRUCTIVE IN THIS PROPOSAL
ABOUT THAT FILM I DON'T LOOK AT
THIS IS A SERIOUS ATTEMPT AND
THEY DON'T IT'S IF YOU'LL TO
FIND SO WE'RE GOING TO DO WE'RE
JUST DOING AN INFANT INVENTORY
AND- REPORT. DATA I DON'T THINK
THAT'S GOING TO HELP WITH WHAT'S
GOING ON ON THE PORCH WHEN THIS
OF MACRO ECONOMIC WORLD ECONOMY.
ISSUE THANK YOU FOR THAT SENATOR
RON. SENATOR CABALLERO. WELL I
HAVE TWO COMMENTS ONE IS- I
REALLY WANT TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT BETTER EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE FUNDING-
BECAUSE THE PARTS ARE A
COMPLICATED BUSINESS. AND- YOU
KNOW I JUST SPENT. I JUST SPENT
THE EIGHT HOURS ON THERE ON THE
ROAD DRIVING UP FROM LA AND THE
NUMBER OF TRUCKS ON THE ROAD IS
SHOCKING- AND REALLY SLOWS DOWN-
THE REST OF THE TRAFFIC AND I'M
WONDERING IS THAT THE BEST WAY
TO MOVE GOODS FROM ONE PART OF
THE STATE TO THE OTHER. IS TO
PUT THEM ON TRUCKS AND- AND MOVE
THEM AROUND- NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO IS THAT IS THAT- I'VE ALSO
SEEN THE- CARRIERS THAT ARE
BRINGING IN THESE THIS THESE
GOODS. PARKED OUTSIDE THE IBM.
THE PORTS AND WE KNOW THAT THOSE
KIDS NEED TO GET TO LAND AND
THEY NEED TO MOVE AND- IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO ME THAT OUR PORTAL IS
GOING TO BE THE SOLUTION TO GET
THAT TO HAPPEN I'M- I'M NOT SURE
I. I'M I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND
IN THAT IN THAT. THAT THAT COULD
JUST BE ME. EXACTLY WHAT THE
WHAT THE- THE PROBLEM IS AND
WHAT'S KEEPING US FROM MOVING
THE THATTHOSE PRODUCTS- AND
THEN FINALLY IT'S- THE QUESTION
I HAVE IS WHETHER THE- THIS MORE
APPROPRIATELY BELONGS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
ARE. RESPONSIBLE FOR GOOD
MOVEMENTS IN THE STATE SO I HAVE
A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS- I I'D
LIKE TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHY A
PORTAL GET TO US. TO MOVE OUR
GOODS FASTER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NO QUESTION WE'VE GOT
TO DO SOMETHING OUR PORTS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. TRUCKS ON
THE ROAD THAT ARE NOT MOVING OR
OR OR SHIPS OUTSIDE OF OUR- OF
OUR- PORTS THAT ARE JUST SITTING
THERE DON'T DON'T HELP IMPROVE
THE AIR QUALITY SO THERE'S NO
QUESTION WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING BUT I'M NOT SURE THIS
IS IT SO. LEAVE IT THERE. ANY
RESPONSE. CENTER CABALLERO YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- SENATORS
SO ALL GREAT GREAT POINTS AND
VERY VALID QUESTIONS- TO YOUR
FIRST POINT REGARDING THE NUMBER
OF TRUCKS ON THE ROAD- AND AS
YOU MENTIONED IN THE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WE'RE SEEING MORE AND MORE
OF THOSE EVERY DAY- AND SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT- IS TAKING
PLACE CURRENTLY IS WORK ON A
FREIGHT THE STATE UNTIL ANY
PLAN- WHICH COST AS YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER ACTUALLY IS.
THAT I LEON WOULD DO CALTRANS-
AND SO WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN INCOME
TAFF- ON THIS- I HAVE THIS
MOVES FORWARD AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY EXACTLY WHAT IT'S
LOOKING AT RIGHT IS WHAT IS THE
BEST WAY TO MOVE- CHECK OUT FOR
A MOMENT OF A CARGO- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THINGS AND PUZZLES
THAT ARE ON THE TABLE AND SO
DEFINITELY MORE TO COME ON I'M
HAPPY TO SHARE SOME INFORMATION
FROM AN ONGOING- ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT NEEDS ON THIS
VERY TOPIC- SO ON ON THAT PERSON
AND THE SECOND PIECE AFTER THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM. AND IT'S
ALSO I THINK GOES. BACK TO. I
SENATOR NIELSEN- ADJUSTER HOW
HOW. YOU KNOW MACRO. AND THAT
THIS REALLY IS THE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT. I MEAN WE ARE WORKING
VERY VERY CLOSE AT HAND WITH HER
COUNTER. ON A REGULAR WE ARE-
WITH THEM I DON'T KNOW TIMES AND
WE- DOING THAT AS A REGULAR
CADENCE OF CHECK AND- WITH OUR
FEDERAL- ARE PARK ON THE WAY. UP
A CAR YOU THAT. HE- WAS LOOKING
CLOSE. ACTORS AT. TO DETERMINE
WHAT IS THE BEST PATH FORWARD WE
KNOW THAT- BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A
COMPLEX SYSTEM OF SYSTEMS. WHERE
THERE ARE MULTIPLE- AS
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED ACROSS THE
ENTIRE SPECTRUM OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN- BUT YET YOU DON'T HAVE
SOME VERY. BASIC INFORMATION
ABOUT CONTAINERS FROM EIGHT IZZY
RIGHT EVEN HOST PORTS AS WE GET
THEM ONTO PROPERTIES AND THEN- I
WANT YOU- YOU KNOW MOVE IT MONEY
ON WHETHER ON RAIL. OR TRUCKS
ETCETERA- WE DON'T HAVE A WE
DON'T REALLY TRACK. THIS
INFORMATION FROM HER MEDIAN AS
WE STOCK- ESPECIALLY THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC WITH THE LACK OF. PP
EQUIPMENT TO OUR FRONT LINE
WORKERS FOR ESSENTIAL WORKERS I
MEAN THIS REALLY JUST- IMPACTED
AS SIGNIFICANTLY- I THINK
SHE'LL. MISTER NELSON AS WELL
EARLIER ABOUT YOU KNOW. KIND OF
WHY WE'RE DOING THAT- SO THERE
pISSUED- IN FALL THAT REALLY
DIRECTED THE GOVERNOR DIRECTED
US ALL TO WORK TOGETHER ON
FINDING- BOTH ASHER AND LONGER
TERM SOLUTIONS. AND ONE OF THOSE
HAS BEEN- THERE'S A RECENT
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WAS MADE-
EARLIER- THIS WEEK WITH THE
USDA- IN REGARD TO OUR AG
EXPORTERS THERE JUST ONE. PLAYER
IT OF THE MANY THAT WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTED. TO THE
TUNE OF TWO POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN JUST. A MATTER OF
MONTHS LAST YEAR I- BUT THEY HIT
JUST DIDN'T. REDUCED THE ECONOMY
AND JUST. WRITER CONTAINERS WERE
SHIPPED BACK TO EACH AND D. N.
R. I. X. WERE REAL STRUGGLING
ESPECIALLY ONLY GROWERS. WHICH
WE ARE A TOP TEN X. AND SO THEY
WERE REALLY STRUGGLING. TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEIR OUT TO MARKET
. AND SO THROUGH THE NAY WITH
CALL THAT CAN. OUR PARTNERS. I
THROUGH YOU. WERE VERY TO WORK
ON THIS- SCIENTISTS CONTAINER.
THIS PUBLIC SECTOR PORT OF
OAKLAND HAS ANNOUNCED A TWENTY
TWO ACRE- ON ON THEIR PROPERTY I
TO BE ABLE TO HELP SPECIFICALLY
WITH. THIS ISSUE AND SO IT
REALLY IS TAKING AN ENTIRE TEAM
IS TAKING ALL HANDS ON DECK. TO
REALLY PUSH YOU AND FINDING
SOLUTIONS AND STUFF- TO YOUR
POINT SENATOR. IN REGARDING
WHETHER THE PORTAL IS
NECESSARILY THE RIGHT APPROACH
WE ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS YOU KNOW
AGAIN ALL SPECTRUMS BUT- CLOSELY
WITH THE POOREST. AND THEY ARE
ULTIMATELY- ALSO PUBLIC
ENTITIES- AND THEY ARE THE
LANDLORDS RIGHT AND SO WE'RE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM. ON
ESTABLISHING WHAT WHAT MAKES ME
LOOK LIKE SO WE WILL HAVE MORE
INFORMATION TO COME I'M HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR TEAM AS
WE DEVELOP. CAN I SEE MY
COLLEAGUE AT FINANCE OTHER HAND. UP TOMORROW I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HAD ANYTHING THAT. THANK YOU
IF I MAY I JUST LIKE TO CLEAR
THAT- THIS- THIS PROPOSAL. IS OF
A MUCH LARGER PROPOSAL FOR THE
FORKS AND WITCHES AND SUPPLY
CHAIN RESILIENCE AND PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE. INVESTMENTS AND
WE'D BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT
PROPOSAL TO- COMMITTEE STAFF IF
THAT'S HELPFUL I'M- WE JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT WE
INCLUDED AT THIS INVESTMENT IN
THE BUDGET. TO SIGNAL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
TRYING TO IMPROVE DATA SHARING
AMONG SUPPORTS AND ALL OF THOSE
PIECES OF THE LARGER PROPOSAL.
AND THE ISSUE OF DATA INTER
OPERABILITY IS COMPLEX THIS IS A
VERY. COMPLICATED ISSUE.
MINISTRATION IS- CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
FURTHER REFINE THIS PROPOSAL AND
WE'RE ALSO MONITORING ON WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING
IN THIS SPACE AS WELL. SO WE
WILL LIKELY SUBMIT AS A SPRING
PER PROPOSAL TO REFLECT THE
OUTCOMES. OF THOSE AND VARIOUS
DISCUSSIONS. THAT'S ALL HELPFUL
THANKYOU MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THE INFORMATION. THANK
YOU SENATOR CAFIERO I JUST WANNA
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT BECAUSE IT
I THINK MISTER WEATHERFORD WAS
BEING KIND WHEN HE SAID IT'S
CHALLENGING TO EVALUATE. SO I
THINK I TOO AM GOING TO WAIT
UNTIL SPRING BECAUSE IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU GUYS NEED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP YOU
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE PROBLEMS
ARE- AND THAT. SORT OF MAKES
SENSE BUT THEN TO EVERYONE'S
POINT IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
COMPLICATED AND NUANCED ISSUE
AND- IT'S ALSO ABOUT FIGURING
OUT WHAT WE HAVE PER VIEW TO DO
. I'M AND- ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
ARE. AND WHAT ALL OF THE REAL
PROBLEMS ARE AND WHAT THE
PROBLEMS ARE THAT WE CAN FIX. SO
MOVING ON THE ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN INCLUSIVE INNOVATION HUB
PROGRAM EXPANSION- GOBIZ. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- THIS IS
REGARDING ACCELERATE CALIFORNIA
INCLUSIVE THE NOVATION HUGS NEED
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO LAUNCH
THE CALIFORNIA IN ADDITION A
HONDA- INCLUSIVE INNOVATION HOW
THE PROGRAM WHICH ESTABLISHES
TEND NOT- THE INCLUSIVE
INNOVATION HUBS TO FOCUS ON
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
IN THE STATE TECHNOLOGY AND
SCIENCE BASED A START UP
COMMUNITIES THE PROGRAM
ENCOURAGES REGIONS TO BUILD UPON
THEIR EXISTING- OR EMERGING
INNOVATION RESOURCES AND LOCAL
INDUSTRY CONCENTRATION TO CREATE
INNOVATION AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP
ACTIVITY HOPS. TO PROMOTE
TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER AND TO
ASSIST NASCENT BUSINESSES WITH A
LAYERED SUPPORT AND PARTNERSHIP
HI THIS PROGRAM ALSO SERVES AS A
BRIDGE BETWEEN LOCAL INNOVATION
ECOSYSTEMS AND STATE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES AND
NETWORKS TO SUPPORT THE SUCCESS
OF THE PROGRAM THE BUDGET
PROPOSES CHANGES- THAT TO
REESTABLISH- WHAT IS CURRENTLY
KNOWN AS I HAD TO PROGRAM AS THE
ACCELERATE CALIFORNIA INCLUSIVE
INNOVATION HUBS PROGRAM AGAIN TO
FOCUS ON THE INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
GROWTH THE BUDGET INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND OVER FOR YEARS. TO
ACCOMPLISH CHIU MAJOR OBJECTIVES
FIRST IS TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
HIGH AYE HUGS FROM TEN TO
THIRTEEN IN REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE AND SECONDLY TO ESTABLISH
THE ENTREPRENEURSHIP FUNDS WHICH
WILL PROVIDE GRANTS OF TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS HER
BUSINESS FOR FIVE NEW BUSINESSES. INCUBATED AT EACH OF THE
ACCELERATE HEALTH HOW. THESE
GRANTS ONE SO AND TECH BASED
BUSINESS CREATE. AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU IS THAT IT
FOR YOU. YES MA'AM OKAY PERFECT
SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I GUESS MS
JOHNSON. YES MA'AM NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE LA
OWES AFTER. YES THANK YOU- THIS
IS BRIAN WITH A FORD WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AGAIN- D.
THIS SERVICE THIS INITIATIVE THE
INCLUSIVE INNOVATION HUB WAS
JUST FUNDED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IS STILL I'M IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING IMPLEMENTED. WE THINK THAT
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
INCLUSIVE INNOVATION HUBS FROM
THIRTEEN I'M SORRY FROM TEN TO
THIRTEEN IN ORDER TO BETTER
ALIGN THE PROGRAM WITH THE SURF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVE
COULD HAVE MERIT. I'M OTHERWISE
WE THINK TO PROVIDING YOU
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM NOW
WOULD BE A BIT PREMATURE AS IT
IN THE NOTES WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT YOU COLLECT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS
BEFORE MAKING FURTHER CHANGES TO
IT. THANK GOD I'M GONNA OPEN IT
UP TO THAT COMMITTEE BRING IT
BACK RATHER SENATOR BICYCLE HE'S
GONE OKAY. SENATOR ROTH. THANK
YOU MANAGER JUST A QUICK
QUESTION- WITH REGARD TO THIS-
INNOVATION HUB PROGRAM HOW DO
YOU PLAN ON HOW HAVE YOU BEEN
PUSHING THE INFORMATION OUT TO
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
REGIONS- SO THAT. THAT
INDIVIDUALS AND ENTITIES NO TO.
KNOW ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY THE
FUNDING AND KNOW THE PROCESS OF
. BY WHICH TO APPLY. WE ARE
LEVERAGING OUR REGIONAL ADVISORS
ON A TWO MAY COME OUR
CONSTITUENTS AVAILABLE ARE
SEIZING- AWARE OF THE AVAILABLE
AND FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO JUST TO
UPDATE THAT THE STATUS OF A
CURRENT TEND NOT I HAD- THAT LA
AND THEN CHEN DO WE ARE ON THE
EXPECTED TO- THAT RELEASED AS
NOTICES OF INTENT TO AWARD THIS
WEEK WE HAD TWENTY TWO
APPLICATIONS- ARE THE
APPLICATION PURITY AND DID IT-
DECEMBER SIXTEENTH TWENTY
WYOMING AND- WE HAVE BEEN IN THE
REVIEW IN THE SELECTION PROCESS
AND SO THAT PROGRAM HE IS MOVING
FORWARD AND WE EXPECT TO
ANNOUNCE AND. TEN AYE HUBS LATER
IN THE WEEK. SO IN TERMS OF
YOUR- I FORGET THE TERM YOU
MANAGER YOUR- YOUR REGIONAL
CONTACTS LEVINE DID DOES THAT
WHAT DOES THAT INCLUDE IS THAT
INCLUDE THE- A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE-
WELL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS I I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE INFORMATION.
IS DISSEMINATED WHO GETS IT IN.
AND I SUPPOSE PROOF'S IN THE
PUDDING SO IF YOU HAD TWENTY
WOULD YOU SAY TWENTY TWO
APPLICANTS THE- FOR THE TEN
SLOTS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO-
ESTABLISH PERHAPS THAT'S GOOD
ENOUGH I'M JUST CURIOUS. I'M YES
SO ARE REGIONALLY FISER SAID AND
WE HAVE A ONE MINUTE WE HAVE
THREE REGIONS IN THE STATE NORTH
CENTRAL AND SOUTH AND- WE HAVE A
REGIONAL ADVISOR ASSIGNED TO
EACH REGION AND THE REGION-
SUPPORTS DEAN ON
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND- SMALL
BUSINESS ECO SYSTEM ACROSS THE
STATE. MOST ESPECIALLY IN THEIR
TERRITORY AND THEY WORK WITH US
ON THAT SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS CHAMBERS
COMMERCE OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- WE HAVE A VERY-
VERY TIGHT AND VERY EFFICIENT-
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OUR NETWORK
OF CENTERS THAT ARE PROVIDING A
WERE UP TO EIGHTY SEVEN NOW THAT
ARE PROVIDING SERVICES TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. IN THIRTY PLUS
LANGUAGES AND IT IS- GOING OUT
TO THAT NETWORK I'M THE IN
ADDITION LOCAL UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES AND THE AND WE GOT
APPLICATIONS FROM YOU KNOW MANY
DIFFERENT. TYPES OF THE AT THE
ENTITIES THAT FIT IN THOSE
POCKETS PERFECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR THE INFORMATION KEEP
DOING A GREAT JOB. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU. SENATOR
KABIR. I APPRECIATE THE IN. ON
THERE WAS JUST PROVIDED AND I DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE- L.
A. O.'S COMMENTS- I'D LIKE TO
KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT-
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROGRAMS-
I GUESS WHAT MY BIGGEST CONCERN
IS WE FIND. THESE HUBS AND WE
WE'VE I THINK WHEN WE'RE GONNA
NEED SOME WAY TO ENSURE THAT
THEY CONTINUE AFTERWARDS SO THEY
WE DON'T JUST FUNDAMENT AND THEY
GO AWAY BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT IT
TAKES- SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES TO BE. DOING WORK WITH
THE SMALL BUSINESSES IT'S A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IT MAKES
ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD
SO MARC MARON'S THAT THAT YOU
CAN GET US. TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE OUTCOMES OF
THE INNOVATION HUBS ARE. AND HOW
THEY EVALUATE THEIR SUCCESS AND
- WHAT THE ECONOMIC BENEFIT
EITHER IS TO THE REGION OR TO
THE BUSINESSES THAT THEY'VE
HELPED- WOULD BE. REALLY HELPFUL
AS WELL. I'M IS CENTER COMING
HERE I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS ON
THE SISTINE ABILITY OF THE ON
INCLUSIVE INNOVATION HUBS
BECAUSE THAT IS AN ISSUE ON A
VISIT LAST YEAR'S FUNDING WAS TO
REBOOT THAT PROGRAM AND ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY THE PROGRAM
NEEDED TO REBOOT IS BECAUSE THE
PREVIOUS PROGRAM DID NOT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING. ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT ONE OF OUR FEARS ABOUT
THE PROGRAM NOW IS EXACTLY WHAT
YOU JUST STATED WE WANT TO
ENSURE THE SUSTAINABILITY AND
LONG TERM VIABILITY OF THE HOT
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE NEED MORE
THAN ONE YEAR FUNDING TO DO SO
EXISTS PROPOSAL HELPS US
ACCOMPLISH THAT SECONDLY WE
WOULD LIKE FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO ATTRACT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND CAPITAL FOR THE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE EACH YOU NEED AN
ACCELERATED TO THESE PROGRAMS
AND WE KNOW THAT SUSTAINABILITY
AND VIABILITY IS IMPORTANT. TO
BEING ABLE TO CREATE A KIND IN
THE ENGINE THAT SUPPORTS
EMERGING ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT. THIS
DIRECTIVE UNICORN. OKAY YOU KNOW
I DON'T EITHER I BEST JUST BEEN
ALERTED THAT WE'RE GOING TO LOSE
THE PHONE LINES AT FIVE SO I'M
GONNA TRY TO JUST COSIGN WITH
SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY-
MY- FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVES TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO STAY IN ABILITY
FIND WE'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
GOBIZ. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
CONGER AND FELLOW SENATORS MY
NAME IS KIND OF VERY SENIOR
ADVISER FOR BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
OVER GO BIZ. WITH THIS
INITIATIVE ARE REQUESTING FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
STARTING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. TO PROVIDE
SHORT TERM GRANTS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FACING SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES TO THEIR NEAR TERM
BUDGET SUSTAINABILITY BUT
DEMONSTRATE A CLEAR COMMITMENT
TO ADVANCING A MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENT AND DIVERSIFIED
ECONOMY. THESE GRANTS WILL
INJECT FUNDS INTO COUNTY LED
PROJECTS THEY'RE AIMED AT
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT ECONOMIC
DIVERSIFICATION CLIMATE
TECHNOLOGY. I LIKED. JOB
MOBILITY AND JOB CREATION. AS
EASY COMPANIES GRAPPLE WITH THE
IMPACTS OF COVER NINETEEN AND
CLIMATE CHANGE. THESE GRANTS
WILL OFFER FINANCIAL FLEXIBILITY
TO THE QUALIFIED COUNTIES IN
EBELING INVESTMENT AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUTURE
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE WITHOUT THE
NEED TO REDUCE UNNECESSARY
ALLOCATIONS FOR VITAL LOCAL
CONSTITUENT SERVICES. ACCORDING
TO QUESTIONS MA'AM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
JOHNSON FINANCE AND NO COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. MISTER WEATHERFORD
. FRAN WHETHER FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE A DETAILED JUSTIFICATION
FOR THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
REQUESTED FOR THE CRITERIA THAT
WOULD BE USED TO MAKE THESE
GRANTS WE KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS STILL
DEVELOPING SOME OTHER RELATED
STATEWIDE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INITIATIVES. STAND AS THE
FUNDING WAS REQUESTED FOR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
IF YOU DO THINK THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR ECONOMIC
DIVERSIFICATION PROJECTS COULD
BE WARRANTED YOU COULD DIRECT
ADMINISTRATION TO RETURN WITH A
MORE MATURE PROPOSAL IN THE NEXT
BUDGET CYCLE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
THAT WAS KIND OF A DROP IN MY-
MISTER VICE CHAIR. MADAM CHAIR I
CERTAINLY RECOMMEND NO ACTION ON
THIS PROBABLY NEVER IN FACT THIS
LOOK LIKE A SLUSH FUND. FOR
GOVERNMENT AND WE DON'T KNOW ANY
IDEA OF THE FOR THE DETAILS A
MATTER OF THIS MAGNITUDE THIS
AMOUNT OF MONEY. SUSTAINING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
EXHAUSTIVELY NEGOTIATED THROUGH
A FULL LEGISLATIVE PROCESS LIKE
THE COMMITTEE HEARINGS NOT JUST
BRIEF SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS AND
THEN A BIG BUDGET HEARING AND
VOTE- WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THIS
IS GOING TO MEAN. WHAT HOW THE
MONEY WILL BE A PORTION. LRGE
SMALL MEDIUM WHAT KIND OF
COUNTIES. CITIES THIS REALLY
CONCERNS ME IS THE IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT WORTHY OF ANY
ACTION TODAY. BUT AT THIS POINT
ARE YOU NOT WORTHY OF INACTION
EVER. ALL RIGHT THANKS FOR THAT-
SENATOR CAFIERO. I HAVE SOME
REAL CONCERNS ABOUT THIS- I
NEEDED TO DO A DETAILED
JUSTIFICATION. I THINK IT'S JUST
THE AMALGAMATION OF A LOT OF
WORDS LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ECONOMIC DIVERSIFICATION I NEED
TO KNOW IT IT'S GONNA FUND
BEFORE I IDEA SUPPORT ITSELF-
THANK YOU SAN ROCK THANK YOU
MANAGER YOU KNOW I SHE- THE- OF
MY COLLEAGUES BUT- THEN
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO KNOW MORE
DETAIL AND TOO OFTEN WE- DO
APPROVE. OF PROPOSALS HERE AND
THIS LEGISLATURE THAT ARE NOT
FULLY- FLUSHED OUT AND WE MAY
NEVER FIND OUT WHAT THE DETAILS
ARE UNLESS WE DO OVERSIGHT BUT-
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE I DO
THINK THAT THERE ARE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE STATE THAT
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY CHALLENGED AND
FUNDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY CHALLENGED
NOT ONLY BY THE PANDEMIC BUT BY
A VARIETY OF OTHER. ACTIONS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO. I THINK THIS THE
CONCEPT BEARS FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND I HOPE WE ARE ABLE TO DO
THAT. THE WEATHER IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE SUB COMMITTEE OR IN THE
LARGER BUDGET COMMITTEE. I ANY
HEARING THAT'S APPROPRIATELY
SIZED TO FIT THE ISSUE. AND MAKE
SOME DECISIONS AS TO WHAT WE DO
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT FUNDING-
IN THIS PARTICULAR STATE SO
THOSE ARE JUST MY COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THANKS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH- I JUST
WANT TO ECHO THAT THERE SEEM TO
BE SOME MERITS TO- THE PROPOSAL
AND YET SAID IS INCREDIBLY.
VAGUE AND AS YOU CAN TELL THESE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LIKE DETAIL
AND JUSTIFICATION SO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY RESPONSE TO
THAT IF NOT WE WILL MOVE ON
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT COMMENT
OR THOSE COMMENTS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
DETAILS. PERFECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH SO ISSUE EIGHTEEN IS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM AND CAPITAL. INFUSION
PROGRAMME. LIKE TO HEAR HEY NOW
FROM GO BUSINESSES MISS GRAY
AGAIN. YOUR CALL WILL AGREE IT
IS INDEED CAROLINE KERR HEY
DIRECTOR CALLOW STA. D. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT INCLUDED
SEVENTEEN MILLION GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY FOR FIVE YEARS TO
ESTABLISH THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EXPANSION PROGRAM. TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO EXPAND
CONSULTING AND TRAINING SERVICES
PROVIDED BY EXISTING AND NEW
CENTERS INCLUDING SATELLITE
OFFICES ON THIS FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED TO OVER EIGHTY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS.
FOR EXPANSION OF THEIR BUSINESS
CONSULTING AND TRAINING SERVICES
TO HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
BUSINESS GROUPS INCLUDING WOMEN
MINORITY AND VETERAN OWNED.
BUSINESSES AND BUSINESSES
LOCATED IN LOW WEALTH RURAL AND
DISASTER IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
SINCE. ITS INCEPTION THAT TAPE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN OVERSUBSCRIBED
THE BUDGET INCLUDES SIX MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND D. AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
TO BOLSTER TATE- TO HANDLE
INCREASED DEMANDS AND TWENTY
THREE MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND TO PERMANENTLY SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM IN ADDITION THE BUDGET
INCLUDES THREE MILLION ON GOING
THE GENERAL FUND BEGINNING.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. A FOUR YEAR
TO SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION OF
THE CAPITAL INFUSION PROGRAMME
WHICH SUPPORTS AT ONE ON ONE
BUSINESS CONSULTING PROVIDED BY
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER NETWORK CENTERS.
SPECIFICALLY TO ASSESS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES IN ACCESSING. CAPITAL
I'LL TAKE QUESTIONS. OKAY GREAT
THANKS GOING TO ASK HERE FOR
SOME OF THE- JOHNSON DEPARTMENT
FINANCE .COM AT THIS TIME THANK
THANK YOU MISTER WEATHERFORD
WITH THE L. A. O.'S OFFICE. YES
THANK YOU- PROVIDING ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS IS
REASONABLE AND WOULD ALLOW THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS TO
HAVE A MORE FINANCIAL CERTAINTY-
WE WOULD ONLY NOTE THAT
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE FUNDING ON
A LIMITED TERM BASIS WOULD
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AND-
LEGISLATIVE FLEXIBILITY. GREAT
THANK YOU I MISTER VICE CHAIR
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU SENATE
ROTH. CENTER CABALLERO THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT I TOO AM WELL I JUST
KNOW THAT SINCE- MISS GRAY SAID
THAT THEY SEEM TO BE OVER
SUBSCRIBED IT WOULD BE GOOD TO
SORT OF CHECK BACK TO SEE HOW
THOSE FOLKS HAVE BEEN DOING BUT
IT SOUNDS PRETTY REASONABLE- I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO COMMENT NOW
IF YOU DON'T WANT. WELL I WOULD
SAY THE I WOULD SAY YES THAT WE-
DO QUARTERLY REPORTING THAT I'M
FROM OUR CENTERS AND COLLECTED
ON THE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
RECEIVING THE ONE ON ONE
CONSULTING. AND TRAINING AND I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE SOME OF THAT
DATA TO YOU. GREAT THANK YOU
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE VERY
HELPFUL. SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN.
GREEN TECHNOLOGIES DEVELOPMENT
CREDITS. LIKE TO HEAR FROM GO
THIS. THIS IS NICK THOMAS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I CAN
TESTIFY IN THIS ONE OKAY GREAT-
THE GREEN TECHNOLOGIES
DEVELOPMENT CREDIT WOULD BE IN
PLACE FROM TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND
WILL PROVIDE A NEW REFUNDABLE
TAX CREDIT FOR COMPANIES
CONDUCTING R&D INTO GREEN ENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE INCLUDE
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE HYDROGEN
TECHNOLOGIES AND LITHIUM
EXTRACTION AMONG OTHERS- THE
CREDIT WOULD BE CAPPED AT ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
AND AWARDS WILL BE MADE. BY A
NEW CLEAN ENERGY BOARD GO BASTER
COMPETITIVE APPLICATION PROCESS
ADDITIONALLY THE CREDIT
AGREEMENTS WILL BE STRUCTURED SO
THAT IF THE BUSINESS BECOMES
PROFITABLE I SHARE PROFITS WILL
BE REPAID TO THE STATE. ALLOWING
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO BENEFIT FROM
THESE CLIMATE INVESTMENTS- THANK
YOU IN WITHOUT ALL. THE THINGS
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. OKAY
GREAT THANK. ALEJO'S OFFERS I'M
NOT YET BUT WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO REVIEW ANY OF THE SPECIFIC
DETAILS OF THIS CONCEPTUAL
PROPOSAL AND SO WERE UNABLE TO
EVALUATE IT AT THIS TIME OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU. MR VICE CHAIR
ANY QUESTIONS. I ASKED THE
LEGEND WAS INDEED TO GIVE CLOSE
SCRUTINY TO THIS. I THINK
THERE'S A- FALSE LOGIC HERE.
CREDITS STRUCTURED THOUGH IF THE
BUSINESS BECOMES PROFITABLE THE
SHARE OF THE PROFITS- WHAT YEAR
10% 5% ONE AND A HALF PERCENT.
GOES TO THE STATE REPAIRED TO
THE STATE. WELL BACK I LOOKS
LIKE A TAX TO ME LET'S CALL OF
THE TAX MAYBE THEY'RE TRYIN
FINANCES TRYING TO GET AROUND
DEEMING THIS A TAX. IT'S A
CREATIVE THOUGHT HERE. BUT I DO
NOT CONSIDER THIS ANY SERIOUS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATOR RON. THANK
THANK YOU SENATOR CABALLERO.
OKAY I THINK WE'VE TH MY VICE
CHAIR KIND OF SEVERAL I THINK
THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT IS IT
EVEN ALLOWABLE- FOR THE
STRUCTURE TO BE IN PLACE WHERE
CREDITS ARE STRUCTURED SO THAT
IF THE BUSINESS BECOMES
PROFITABLE SHARE OF THE PROFITS
GETS REPAID TO THE STATE THAT I
DON'T KNOW AND OTHER QUESTIONS
AROUND CRITERIA AND PROJECT
DETERMINANTS SO I WOULD HOPE
THAT. WE ARE HOLDING IT OPEN BUT
THOSE KINDS OF QUESTIONS CAN BE
ADDRESSED. YEAH I WILL
DISCONNECT HONEST WITH FINANCE-
WE'RE STILL IN THE EARLY STAGES
OF DEVELOPING THIS PROPOSAL AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SHARING MORE
DETAILS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU FORMATH FACTS SO MUCH
I'M NEXT IS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
HUMAN RESOURCES STAFFING- GOBIZ. YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JIM TÌM I'M
CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DIVISION FOR BUILDERS. ARE WE
REQUESTING HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND
I'M GOING GENERAL FUND TO
INCREASE GOBIZ HUMAN RESOURCES I
JUST ONE DECISION. AFTER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS WE HAVE GROWN BY
SIXTY SIX PERCENT. IN
LEGISLATORS INCREASE THE
RESPONSIBLE USE OF OUR APARTMENT
IN TURN WE MAKE THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU THANK YOU L. A. L.'S OFFICE
. BRIAN WEATHERFORD WITH THE L.
A- AND WE ARE NOT RAISING
CONCERNS AT THIS PROPOSAL- THE
PROGRAMMATIC RESPONSIBILITIES OF
GO BIZ HAVE BEEN EXPANDED OVER
RECENT YEARS AND- THAT
REASONABLY CAUSES- MANAGEMENT
GENERAL MINISTRY OF EXPENSES
INCREASES WELL. TRUE THAT TRUE
THAT MR VICE CHAIR ANY QUESTIONS
. SENATOR ROB NO MA'AM SENATOR
CABALLERO OKAY AND NOTHING FOR
ME OUR WHICH TAKES US TO THE
LAST LARGE ITEM WHICH IS A STATE
COMPTROLLER'S. ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PAYROLL SYSTEM PROJECT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS MY NAME
IS JENNIFER URBAN AND I'M THE
CHIEF OF BUDGETS AND ACCOUNTING
WITH THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE WE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PAROLE SYSTEM
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL. AS HE
WAS REQUESTING INCREASED
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE C. S.
P. S. PROJECT THROUGH THE
CONTINUATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE. THREE THESE
RESOURCES ARE CRITICAL TO THE
PROJECT SUCCESS AS A SOLUTION
DESIGN DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION WILL COMMENCE AS
A PROJECT ANTICIPATES SELECTING
A SYSTEM INTEGRATOR IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. IN
ADDITION THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES AS A PRIMARY BUSINESS
PARTNER ON THE PROJECT IS
REQUESTING RESOURCES TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE NEXT PHASE OF
THE PROJECT AND TO ADHERE TO
REQUEST FOR PROJECT RELATED
ACTIVITIES WITHIN THE AGREED
UPON TIMELINE. THESE RESOURCES
WILL ENABLE KALINJAR
SUCCESSFULLY MANAGE THE H. R.
COMPONENT OF THE LARGE SCALE
STATEWIDE PROJECTS. WITH ME
TODAY IS CHRIS MAILED THE CS PS
PROJECT DIRECTOR IN HOME NOW
PROVIDE A STATUS UPDATE ON THE
PROJECT. OKAY MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS MAYO
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM
PROJECT AT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. AS
MISERABLE AND MENTIONED THE C.
S. P. S. PROJECT CONTINUES
WORKING THROUGH THE STATE FOUR
STAGES OF THE PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFE CYCLE KNOWN AS POWELL. WAS
STAGE ONE HAVING BEEN APPROVED
BACK IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IN STAGE TWO HAVING
BEEN APPROVED IN APRIL AND JUST
LAST YEAR. OVER THE LAST YEAR
THE PROJECT TEAM HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY STATEWIDE TECHNOLOGY
PROCUREMENT DIVISION ON STAGE
THREE ACTIVITIES. THAT INCLUDE
DEVELOPING SOLICITATION
MATERIALS SUCH AS THE REQUEST
FOR PROPOSAL IN THE STATEMENT OF
WORK. AND FINALIZING THE
EVALUATION METHODOLOGY. THE
STATE STREET IS NEARING ITS AND
THE PROJECT TEAM IS LOOKING
FORWARD TO STAGE FOR PROCUREMENT
ACTIVITIES TO BE SCHEDULED OUT
OVER THE NEXT YEAR THAT WILL
INCLUDE A BETTER QUALIFICATION
PHASE A PROOF OF CONCEPT PHASE.
AND FINALLY AN NEGOTIATION PHASE
ALL CULMINATING IN THE
IDENTIFICATION THE SOFTWARE
SOLUTION AND SYSTEMS INTEGRATION
BENDER IT'S AT THIS POINT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THE
PROJECT BEFORE IT PROCEEDS WITH
CONTRACT EXECUTION. PROJECT TEAM
CONTINUES TO MANAGE THE PROJECT
WITH ALL THE RIGOR REQUIRED FOR
A PROJECT OF THIS SIZE AND
COMPLEXITY. AS I'VE SAID BEFORE
AND I'LL KEEP SAYING IT AGAIN
THAT HOW IS THIS PROJECTS
FRIEND. IS IT DEMANDS FOLLOWING
A VERY DISCIPLINED APPROACH TO
PROJECT MANAGEMENT. BUDGET TEAM
APPRECIATES THE OVERSIGHT
PROVIDED BY THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGIES PROJECT APPROVAL
AND OVERSIGHT DIVISION. AND THE
PROJECT'S OWN CONTRACTED
INDEPENDENT VERIFICATION AND
VALIDATION VENDOR IN THE PROJECT
MAKES COURSE CORRECTIONS BASED
ON THEIR ADVICE. BOTH OF THESE
OVERSIGHT PROVIDERS OF SERVICES
TO DOUBLE CHECK AND BALANCE OF
THE PROJECT DURING THE PLANNING
PHASE. FINALLY THE PROJECT
ACTIVELY MONITORS RISKS AND
ISSUES AND REPORTS THEM TO THE
EXECUTIVE STEERING COMMITTEE AT
ITS BI MONTHLY MEETINGS. TO
ENSURE SWIFT ACTION IS TAKEN TO
ADDRESS THEM. BUDGET ALSO
PRODUCES MONTHLY PERFORMANCE
SCHEDULE AND RISK AND ISSUE
REPORTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
REVIEW BY ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
BANKERS EVERYONE TO REVIEW THESE
REPORTS BECAUSE THEY DO CONTAIN
VALUABLE INFORMATION IN THE
INSURANCE ALL STAKEHOLDERS
REMAIN INFORMED ABOUT THE
PROGRESS OF THE PROJECT. AND THE
RISK IN ISSUES THAT IT FACES
WITH THAT'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
. SO WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA ICBM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NO ALL
THE OFFICE IS THE BRIAN METZ
HERE WE GO. HELLO BRIAN MINSKER
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE PLANNING DOLLARS IN
POSITIONS IN THIS PROPOSAL BUT
THE FOR ITS CONSIDERATION OF THE
REMAINING EIGHTY THREE POINT
THREE MILLION IN FUNDING. FOR
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR WE
REYES THREE MAIN CONCERNS WITH
APPROVING DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDS AT THIS
TIME. FIRST THE LEGISLATURE DOES
NOT HAVE ADEQUATE INFORMATION
NOW TO APPROVE THESE FUNDS KEY
PIECES OF INFORMATION ARE NOT
AVAILABLE INCLUDING A FINAL
BASELINE COST SCHEDULE AND SCOPE
FOR THE PROJECT FIND A VENDOR
CONTRACTS AND OTHER SUPPORTING
PROJECT DOCUMENTATION. SECOND
THE PROJECTS ASSUME TIMELINE TO
COMPLETE PLANNING IS OPTIMISTIC.
DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR CURRENT AND
POSSIBLE FUTURE DELAYS FROM
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES
PROCUREMENT AND OTHER RELATED
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS AGREEMENTS
FROM BARGAINING UNITS AND
INTEGRATIONS WITH OTHER SYSTEMS
SUCH AS FRISCO. THIRD THE
PROJECTS PROPOSED SCHEDULE
PROVIDES THE ADMINISTRATION WITH
FLEXIBILITY TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT THE PROJECT BUT AT THE
COST OF LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
THE PROPOSED THE S. P. S. I. T.
PROJECT IF APPROVED WOULD BE ONE
OF THE COSTLIEST AND MOST
COMPLEX IT PROJECTS UNDERTAKEN
BY THE STATE. THE PRELIMINARY
COST ESTIMATE FOR THIS PROJECT
IS SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
WITH THE PRELIMINARY TIMELINE OF
FIVE AND A HALF YEARS FOR
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
THAT AFFECTS MANY STATE
DEPARTMENTS. WE FIND THAT THE
BENEFITS OF STARTING THE
PROJECTS DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF FEW MONTHS
EARLIER DO NOT OUTWEIGH THE
RISKS OF OUR HURRIED LEGISLATIVE
REVIEW OF THE PROJECT PLAN. AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKEY DOKEY. MISTER VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN SENATOR RON. I DON'T
EVEN KNOW IF I WANNA STIRRED
MADAM CHAIR I. I'M YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN THROUGH SEVERAL OF THESE
BIG IT PROJECTS WHILE SITTING ON
HIS COMMITTEE PER TO MY
SABBATICAL. IT. SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS I THOUGHT WE
WERE DOING IT PROCUREMENT IN
SMALLER BITE SIZE COMPONENTS
THAT GAVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
. EXPLORE FUNCTIONALITY- ADDENDA
FIVE RISKS OF DEFICIENCIES AND
REPAIR. IS THAT CONCEPT EMBEDDED
IN THIS IN THIS IN THIS PROJECT
. ACTUALLY IT IS THE WAY WE HAVE
FORMED- THE STATEMENT OF WORK IN
OUR REQUIREMENTS WE ARE YOU KNOW
POSING THAT QUESTION TO THE
VENDOR COMMUNITY TO SEE YOU
KNOW. WHAT IMPLEMENTATION
APPROACH DO THEY RECOMMEND FOR
THE SIZE OF PROJECT IT'S QUITE
POSSIBLE THAT THEY'LL COME BACK
WITH A PROPOSAL THAT DOES DO
WHAT YOU'RE EXACTLY SAYING
ALTERNATIVELY THEY MIGHT YOU
KNOW RECOGNIZE THAT A LOT OF THE
LINES OF BUSINESS OUR INTERVIEW
LATED AND THEY'LL SAY WE THINK
WE SHOULD IMPLANT YOU ALL OF THE
FUNCTIONALITY BY PHASES OF
DEPARTMENT AS OPPOSED TO
INDIVIDUAL LINES OF BUSINESS
BUT- ANSWER YOUR QUESTION YES
THIS IS REALLY OPPOSED TO THE
VENDOR COMMUNITY TO PROPOSE BACK
TO THE STATE- THE CORRECT
IMPLEMENTATION METHODOLOGY. WELL
I APPRECIATE THAT RESPONSE AND
AS I. SUSPECTED BEFORE PRESERVES
ASKING MY QUESTION AND MY
QUESTION PERHAPS. IS A BIT
PREMATURE AND THAT YOU WILL NEED
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH YOUR
PLANNING PROCESS AND AT SOME
POINT- WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS AS YOU
EXPLAIN. YOUR BUSINESS PLAN FOR
MOVING THIS FORWARD- THERE IS
CLEARLY NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM PROJECT
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE-
YEARS AGO AS I RECALL IT WAS
ATTEMPTED YEARS AGO- AND THE
SYSTEM WE'RE USING TODAY- AS I
RECALL- IS USING- PROGRAMMING-
TECHNIQUES THAT. WAS IN PLACE
WHEN I WAS A FRESHMAN IN COLLEGE
WHICH- IS A LONG TIME AGO SO
THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING TO WORK
ON THIS CONTENT THANK YOU TO THE
TEAM FOR. CONTINUING TO- TO DO
WHAT THEY DO AND MOVE THIS
FORWARD AND THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING UP WITH MY QUESTION.
YOUR MANAGER THANK YOU SENATOR
ROCKWELL I SUPPORT ANYTHING THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO. PAY STATE
EMPLOYEES MORE EFFICIENTLY. AND
IT'S A HUGE. DOLLAR AMOUNT- AND
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS ASKED
BY SENATOR ROTH BECAUSE I HAD
SIMILAR ONES- JUST ABOUT THE
GENERAL STRUCTURE. ALSO ABOUT
SORT OF LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
WITH THIS PROCESS YOU KNOW IF A
VENDOR HASN'T BEEN SELECTED.
KNOW WHAT ROLE CAN WE PLAY AND
BEING SUPPORTIVE IN THAT- BUT
THIS SEEMS LIKE THE BEGINNING
STEPS OF A JOURNEY. YES I SEE
SILENCE I WILL EXACTLY SHAKING
HEADS OKAY VERY GOOD SO WITH
THAT- IF NO ONE ELSE DOES ANYONE
ELSE HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD THAT'S
ON CAN ASSUME WORLD. NOW OKAY.
SO WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA SO AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN TWO SEVEN SIX TWO
TWO. FOUR SIX TWO. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY AND I'M GOING TO DO
THAT TODAY I AM TELLING YOU THAT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC PROVIDING
COMMENT. PLEASE KEEP THEIR
REMARKS WITHIN ONE MINUTE
BECAUSE WE ALSO HAVE A TIME LINE
WITH REGARDS TO- HAVING ACCESS
TO THE PHONE LINES. NOW LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. I SEE SOMEONE.
GO HEAD SIR. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ALEX TORRES WAS STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. WANAKA COMMENTS HE
MADE AN ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB FOR
REGARDING IN USE GRANT PROGRAM
BY FOR STATE OUR THANKS TO
DIRECTOR GRAY- THE CALIBER TEAM
IN THE GOBIZ TEAMS WERE BEING
EXTREMELY RESPONSIVE AND
RECEPTIVE TO OUR CONCERNS WE
HAVE SOME POTENTIAL FIXES TO
ISSUES REFERENCE DATE WITH NEXT
CODES AND OTHER ISSUES- THAT WE
WORK TOGETHER ON- WITH
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES AND
CAL NONPROFITS FIXES THAT WE
THINK MAKES SENSE AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT. THAT
CONVERSATION- COALITION IS
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE WE'RE
MAXIMIZING THESE FUNDS WERE
WORRIED ABOUT IS THE EXISTENCE
OF LEFTOVER FUNDS FROM THIS
PROGRAM THAT COULD HAVE GONE TO
WAR THE APPLICANTS.WHO WERE
EITHER DENIED OR JUST DIDN'T
APPLY UNDER SOME OF THESE
UNINTENTIONAL DISQUALIFIER IS.
ON THE CONVERSATION ON MOVIE
THEATERS THE PROGRAM WAS
INITIALLY CONCEIVED BY OUR
AFOREMENTIONED COALITION OF ARTS
ADVOCATES WITH A FOCUS ON LIVE
EVENTS AND INDEPENDENTLY OWNED
ENTITIES- THE INDEPENDENTLY
OWNED MOVIE THEATERS WERE
INITIALLY ENGAGED IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS BUT FELL OFF ALONG
THE WAY BUT I UNDERSTAND EVERY
CASE WE HAVE HAD SOME INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM- GIVEN
THE NUMBER OF OTHERWISE. VENT
THEN USED- OPTED TO NOT A OR
OTHERWISE INELIGIBLE BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THESE BARRIERS. IN
ADDITION TO MOVIE THEATERS WHO
OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T APPLY. WE'RE
VERY EAGER TO DISCUSS THE
POSSIBILITY OF AN AUGMENTATION
TO THIS PROGRAM ALONG WITH A
SECOND ROUND OF APPLICATIONS
WITHIN AMENDED ELIGIBILITY
GUIDELINES. SO WE CAN CAPTURE
ALL OF THESE FOLKS THAT HAVE
BEEN HARMED BY THE PROVIDER
SHUTDOWNS NOTABLY THE ONLY CRIME
VARIANT WHICH- YOU KNOW IT IT
JUST BECAUSE THE PROGRAM PASSED
DIDN'T MEAN. SHOWS YOU KNOW.
STOPPING STOP RIGHT THERE-
MAKRAN VARIANT SHUT DOWN A LOT
MORE SHOWS. MOVIE THEATERS WERE
SHUT DOWN WHETHER THROUGH
CONSUMER CONCERNS AROUND
GATHERINGS OR OTHER PUBLIC
SAFETY GUIDELINES SO WE WANT TO
BE SURE TO PUT A FLAG. UP AND
SAY WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE
AUGMENTATION A SECOND ROUND I
THINK WOULD. CAPTURE ALL THE
CONCERNS FROM ALL THESE
ADVOCATES AND- REALLY HELP THESE
BUSINESSES- RESUME OPERATION
EFFECTIVELY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM- QUEUED UP SO
MODERATE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
YOU. IF OU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BEGIN. S. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
VIA THE PHONE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW AGAIN ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ZERO EIGHT OAKLAND
CAROLINE. NOW WE HAVE EIGHT AND
HOUR AFTER TEN OKAY TEN OKAY
WELL LET'S DO IT. HEY HELLO SIR
WHAT LINE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS
SOPHOMORE INTERNET ON BEHALF OF
INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE AND
WAREHOUSE UNION LOCALS. THIRTEEN
SIXTY NINETY FOUR COMMENTING ON
ITEM- NATION NUMBER FIFTEEN ARE
WE HAVE CONCERNS REGARDING THE
PROPOSAL WE ARE WORKING WITH
GOAL THERE. THE FIGURE OUT
LANGUAGE ON HOW NIGHT NOT UT
PUBLIC FUNDS TO TRACK OF MINERS
THAT PRODUCTIVITY OF THE
WORKFORCE OF THE PORT- WE HAVE
SOME NEIGHBORS- IN A BARGAINING
CONTRACT ON PROVISIONS THAT WE
OFTEN DON'T WANT TO BE IN
VIOLATION. SO ARE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH COPAYS AND
THE POOR COMMUNITY HIGH TO
ENSURE THAT THAT FUNDS ARE NOT
USED TO TRACK THE PRODUCTIVITY.
OF THE WORKFORCE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THEY YOU. MAXWELL HELLO
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HELLO MY NAME IS ANNA FROM
. AND I AM TWENTY POLITICIAN
NUMBER BACKING A CHANCE AB OUT
EMAIL THEN YOU CAN WRITE CANNOT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AND I
THINK THAT THE BOND NOT AS WELL
I MEAN DELAY. ATTY IRAQ INTO
KIND OF HIT. I THANK YOUNG
TEENAGERS BY FACT BECAUSE
INCREDIBLE. I IT CALMS MARC THAT
I TIMES BUT CAN YOU RUN I MEAN I
HAPPEN UNTIL. ONE ONE HI. MANY
OF THESE ARE GRANT MY FAMILY THE
OUT WHAT I REMEMBER THEY WOULD
BE A GOOD- COLOR BLIND THANK OF
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT. NOT A
BENEFIT FOR OUR STATE AND OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY DON'T STOP THANK
YOU FOR READING. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT MAXWELL LONG TERM
LINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
STIMULATE MONEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
THE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION FOR
THE STATE TRAVEL AND TOURISM
INDUSTRY I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE TWELVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ALLOCATION OF FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS EXTENDED
THE CALIFORNIA MARKETING
CAMPAIGN. THE CONTINUED LAST
NIGHT AS CRITICAL AS THE TOURISM
ECONOMY ESPECIALLY IN URBAN
CENTERS EXPERIENCE WITH A
LOPSIDED RECOVERY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER. MAXIMO CAROLINE THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND SHARED NORMS
BOTTOM ALL OF THE BODY
CALIFORNIA. FOUNDATION PART OF
THE ISSUE SEVEN WELL BASICALLY
PARTNERSHIP. EDUCATION WORK ON
NUMBER YOU OR KNOW THE ON THE-
FUNNY AND COMPROMISED PENDING
THAT LEGAL AND POLITICAL UNDER
MY- THAT IMPACT OUR LITTLE BIT
ADVANTAGE ARE COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU TO CONFIRM THAT OKAY SHOULD
GRADUATE WILL BE ALL THE-
OUTLETS AND BLOODBATH AFTER.
FROM DATA WORK ALL. WE ARE ALSO
IN ISSUE. INTEGRATION ALTHOUGH
ALONG WITH THE NEW. CORRECT OF
THE INSPIRATION FOR THE OKAY
ACCORDING TO A LOCAL COURT NAY
AND IT WRAPUP ECONOMIC BUT NOT
FOR INTENDED COMMUNITY AND
BENEFIT THEY ARE. IF WILL GO
ALONG WAY PART. INDEED AFFECTED
IN PROBABLY MEASURE- ZERO EIGHT
FOUNDATION YOUR RECOMMENDATION
FOR YOUR BOARD AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LIKE AND YET
MANY I'M SURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MODERATOR CALLER
. MAX KALAW THIRTY THREE PLEASE
AHEAD- YEAH CHAIRMEN ROB MOTION
THE HEALTH CHAMBER COMMERCE
CALLING AT THE PORT OF THE
RECALL OR FORTY FIVE CHIU
PREVENT HEALTH TO HELP REBUILD
HELPFUL USED INCOME WHICH I AM
ON THE WORD HIT IN THE IN THIS
DURING AND I'M ACTUALLY THINK
THAT AGO USE OF THE FUN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MONTEREY NEXT
CALLER. NEXT CAROLINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'M I'M GONNA BE OUT
THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION OUTSIDE COMMON ISSUE
TWELVE RELATED TO TOURISM H. A.
T. H. L. A. SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO SPEND
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
SPECIFICALLY EXTENDED THAT
CALIFORNIA'S MEDIA CAMPAIGN-
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO CONTINUE
ATTRACTING BUSINESS. OF THE
TOURISM ECONOMY RECOVERS. I
REQUEST COMMITTEE IS GOING UP
ALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. MAXIMO TO
LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE SAID- COUNTY. I AM VERY
NEED. YEAH DEVELOPMENT THE WORD
WITH ANY. I THINK. I. WHY HERE.
JOB ARE AM. YEAH THERE. I THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR SIGNING.
THANK YOU MY NEXT CALLER.
MAXIMUM THE LINE THIRTIES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ABOUT TEN MINUTES AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S HOW
THEY ON ON THE OF TRYING ALL AND
BACK CA WE THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSED INVESTMENT ALIVE AND BE
SURE NUMBER FOR A KING ON
IMMIGRATION IMMIGRATION AND
TRYING TO BUY ONE. J. A. R. P.
SHAPE THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET MUST
ON TOUR IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION I
THINK OUR MODERN COMMUNITY HAS
STRUGGLED SO MUCH. ENERGY AND
THE COVER FROM THE PANDEMIC A
BILLION HE WON WITH A
STRENGTHENED INFRASTRUCTURE NEED
TO OUT OF STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS
INCLUDES ALL COMES OFF AND
INCREASE THE QUALITY OF LIFE ALL
OUT IN THE. COMMUNITY THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CALLER. THANKS TELL TO
ONE THE GO AHEAD. SENATOR YOUR
THE CALIFORNIA FOR THE PORT OF
IMMIGRANTS THIS IS BETWEEN THE
ALLOCATION OF THE FUNDS BECAUSE
THE NSF I REMEMBER AS A
COMMERCIAL MANAGER WITH
IMMIGRANT TRADING WITH THE PARK
ON THE GRASS IMMIGRANTS WRITING
ACROSS THE SERVER AND DOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY AND GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE TRAINING
FUNDING AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO OVER SIX HUNDRED IMMIGRANT
ENTREPRENEURS ACROSS THE-
BASEBALL. ACROSS THE STATE IN
THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS WE
LEARNED A GREAT DEAL ABOUT THE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
ENTREPRENEUR COMMUNITY
SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE LEARNED
ABOUT THE NEED FOR BAYSIDE I
DON'T KNOW IF THE TRAINING
LANGUAGE ACCESSIBILITY TO
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND THE NEED FOR
ACCESS TO CAPITAL AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SO HOW IMMIGRANT
ENTREPRENEURS FAR ACROSS EIGHT
BUSINESS. THE UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT ENTREPRENEUR
POPULATION HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY
NEGLECTED AND EXCLUDED FROM
SUPPORT BUT HAS NONETHELESS
CONTRIBUTED TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC GROWTH- GENERATING
THREE FOUR POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN BUSINESS AND INCOMES
I THINK YOU'RE GETTING ONE POINT
NINE BILLION IN THE A LOCAL
TAXES IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS IS
MY IMMIGRANT FIGHTING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
WE NEED A DEDICATED POSITION TO
HANDLE IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
ACROSS THE STATE. SPECIFICALLY
YOU KOBE IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
NEEDS OF THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY ARE CONSIDERED AND
ADDRESSED WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
EIGHT POINT SEVEN MILLION A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND INTENDS AND
INTENDED TO HOLD GOVERNMENT
EXPENSE REPORT APARTMENT GROUNDS
FOR NORTH MOREOVER WE SUPPORT
THE FIND A LOCATION THAT HAVE
BIG. INFORMATION AND REPORTS OF
THE PRIORITY LANGUAGES I THIS IS. A BIG NEED AMONG THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY. WELCOME OTHER HIGH
DEMAND FOR. SHIP AND TECH THIS
WE CAN OFFER NOT AVAIL TO OUR
DOCUMENTS ENTREPRENEUR. WE'RE
ALSO SUPPORTER ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN I'M GOING AS TECHNICAL
AS AS OF. FOR THE COMMUNITY
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
I THINK FOR YOUR- A LOCAL UP
WITH ANY DURING STEP FURTHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY- THE LAST
CALL. WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR MORE IN
THE QUEUE AT MY ONCE VICE. WE GO
OVER TO LINE THEIR FIVE PLEASE
BY. MADAM CHAIR RETIREMENT AND
COLIN FOR HUMANE INTO RIGHT NOT
. TWO ITEMS THAT AND ALL CAN
PART AND STRATEGIC COMMUNICATION
. R- I HOPE THAT THE EFFORT IS
IMPLEMENTED WITHIN EQUITY LAN
AND WITH A FOCUS ON WORKING WITH
THE HEARING YOUR HELP IN GETTING
THE AND THE DIRECTION OF THIS
WORK AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER-
WE HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN
PARTICULAR CHIRLA.
COLLABORATIONS WITH THE STATE TO
HELP PUSH PROGRAM FORWARD AND
GET THE WORD OUT IN CRITICAL
MOMENTS AND SHALL WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE THAT WORKS AND I REGARD
TO ITEM THIRTEEN IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSAL WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED TO SEE THE FIRST
THAT I WAS NOT. THINKING ABOUT
WHAT IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION THANK
YOU WIDE PERSPECTIVE SHE HAS
BEEN WORKING FOR MANY YEARS- AT
PUSHING THE STATE TO INVEST IN
INTEGRATION IN OUR BUREAUCRATIC
STRUCTURE AND THEN WE WANT TO
SUPPORT THE FIRST STEP FORWARD
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
DIRECTOR POSITIONS IT'S VERY
EXCITING AS WELL AS A BUNDLE OF
MONEY FOR A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COUNTY IT USED TO BE ABLE TO.
HAVE GRANT TO PUSH FORWARD THEIR
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION WORK AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IN A WAY THAT
MAKES SENSE FOR THEM WE HOPE TO
BUILD ON THIS SO THAT WE CAN
MAXIMIZE IMPACT AND MOVE OUR
STATE FORWARD AND ALONG WITH
OTHER STATE THAT HAVE INVESTED
IN IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. MAXIMO THE LINE FOUR.
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. AFTER THE AND
CHAIRMAN MAY DEALS REPRESENT CAL
BAN CHAMBERS COM. RECALLING
SUPPORT OF A THIRD. THE
IMMIGRATION IMMIGRATION AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PROPOSAL
THIS PROPOSAL I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE WOULD WOULD PROVIDE
TREMENDOUS SERVICE CHORE
IMMIGRANT SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
SUPPORT ON THE EXPANSION OF THE
EXPORT TRAINING NETWORK AND
GROWING BILATERAL TRADE
INVESTING BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO. BERMAN BERMAN ALSO
SUPPORT OF ISSUE SIXTEEN
INCLUSIVE INNOVATION HOW PROGRAM
EXPANSION. PLEASE I HAVE WILL
LOOK SUPPORT. INCUBATORS AND
SMALL BUSINESS CENTERS THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO DIVERSE
SMALL BUSINESS START UPS
DEVELOPING THEIR BUSINESS PLAN
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES. ALSO
WERE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE EIGHTEEN THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE EXPANSION PROGRAM. I
THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES INTRAPRENEURS
THEY NEED ADDITIONAL HELP WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND ALSO
WITH THE FINANCING FOR THE
SUCCESS OF THEIR BUSINESS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ONGOING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MANY MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. MAXIMUM OF THE LINE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER OPEN ARTS ADVOCATES WANT
TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION KERN CLEANING
CALIFORNIANS ARTS AND CULTURE
NONPROFIT INCREASED BUSINESS IN
A SMALL COMPANY SMALL BUSINESS
COMPANY CAN RELEASE GRANT
PROGRAM AND CALIFORNIA I NEED
PROGRAM I THINK I THANK HAS
NEARLY CAL BA AND THE DENNIS
FIRE DEPARTMENT TWENTY MILLION
OF FUNDING THAT OUR MAIN AREN'T
ALLOCATED. AMOUNT AND IF I FOR
NONPROFIT CULTURE INSTITUTIONS
WE AGREED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONSIDER THAT THERE ARE
VERY WARM NONPROFIT CULTURE
CONDITIONS AND ACCESSING THE
FUNDS AND THE DEATH ADDITIONAL
CHANGES THE LEGISLATION TO FULLY
UTILIZE FUNDING FOR THE PARKING
ANY INSTITUTION AS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED I'M A CON AND CONTINUE
CLOSURES MAINLY WE KNOW THAT
THEY NEED AND WE HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL COME BETTER
INCLUDE ANY CHANGES AND WE OPEN
GRANT PROGRAMS THE TWENTY
MILLION EARLY. ACTION INTO
ELEVEN THIRTEEN. CALLAWAY A HAS
BEEN CLASS WITH OPENING AND- THE
- MEDIAN GENDER ISSUES. IN
ADDITION THE NECK. CODE IS THAT
WE TO ABOUT ELIGIBLE TO APPLY.
AND BECOME IMPEDIMENT TO
REALIZING THE- POTENTIAL FOR THE
- I NEED GRANT. WE ALSO HER THAT
CONNECTS HE HE TRIED. TO THIS
PRO. THE FUNDING INTENT KENDRA
OF THE- AND- OF KOBE NINE ECHO
LAKE. OPINION AND IS THANK YOU.
p. SACRAMENTO THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
PORT OF LONG BEACH AND THE COURT
AND ITEM FIFTEEN- WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
INCLUSION IN THIRTY NINE CLICK
OPEN. AND OPERATIONAL PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT OF THE COURT- THIS
INVESTMENT WILL ALLOW FOR THE
COURT TO THE COURT R. IG
PARTNERS BY PROVIDING- SECURE
ACCESS TO DATA TO HELP THEM TO
BETTER PLAN CONTROL AND TRACK
CARGO MOVING ACROSS MULTIPLE
MODES OF TRANSPORTATION AND
THEY'RE BY EATING AT AND- THAT
CONTRACTUAL SHOWS THAT WE'RE
HEARING I THANK THE COURT. FOR
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
MICHAEL INCIDENTS PRO BOWL AND I
AM THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MODERATOR. HOW MANY MORE FOLKS
WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE. WE HAVE
THREE MORE LAST OKAY. NEXT
AREN'T MAXIMO TO LINE FORTY ONE
. GET AFTERNOONHERE COMMENTARY
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER HEARING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MEDIUM AND CAL
NONPROFIT AND WE WANT TO THANK
THE LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR ONGOING
SUPPORT FOR INCLUSION OF
NONPROFITS AND STATE WILL NEED
PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE SMALL
BUSINESS OF THE NINETEEN RELIEF
AND THE CALIFORNIA VENUES GRANT
PROGRAM. HE HAVE ANY CONTINUE TO
BE CRITICAL FOR OUR SECTOR WE
ALSO LIKE TO COMMENT ON THE
REMAINING THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE SMALL BUSINESS OF THE
NINETEEN RECAP PROGRAM THAT
CULTURE FROM THE CULTURAL
INSTITUTION. WHICH ARE VERY
STRONGLY THAT ANY OF THOSE
REMAINING FUNDS FROM THE COLD
FRONT ISSUES AROUND MUST BE USED
TO HELP THE ARTS AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS BURKE HOTTER
FUNDING WITH INITIALLY INTENDED
MANY MUSEUMS AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS HAVE NEEDED TO SHUT
DOWN AGAIN AND CANCEL THAT
BECAUSE OF THE ON THE KANERIA WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
CALIBEX STAFF MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING FOR CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT ADDRESS
ANOTHER THEIR YOUR SWEET DEAL
PREVENTED CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
FROM APPLYING. AS WELL AS ALLOWS
BACKING GRANT ENTITIES WITH
EXTREME FINANCIAL NEED AND WE
WOULD LIKE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT
EFFORT THANK YOUNG THANK. YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. MAXIMO TO
LINE UP FOR. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND SHERMAN ARE
GOAL ON BEHALF OF KERR SIGN AND
I NUMBER FIVE- WE WANTED YEAH
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS TWENTY
DOLLARS IN THE RELOCATION OF THE
CARNEGIE INSTITUTION FOR SCIENCE
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A MOBILE
SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WILL REACH OUT TO ASK IF YOU
CARNEGIE SHOULD BE D. S. NOT A
CREAMIER I SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
INSTITUTION IN SUCH AN IMPORTANT
SCIENTIFIC AREAS SUCH AS CLIMATE
CHANGE. MINISTER CREATE IN
DALLAS IN NINETEEN OH TWO WITH A
SINGULAR FOCUS ON SOLVING THE
MOST PRESSING SCIENTIFIC PROBLEM
THE NEW WORLD WIDE CENTER OF
SCIENTIFIC DISCOVERY WELL WE'RE
COLLABORATING ON STRATEGIES TO
SOLVE ENVIRONMENTAL BIOLOGICAL
AND ENERGY TRAT CALIFORNIA AND
WORLD THE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT. STATE
OF THE ART FACILITY HIGHLIGHTED
THE COST ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS EVEN
RIGHT TO PRIVATE BOND AND WE
BELIEVE THE ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION FROM THE STATE WILL HELP
PUT THAT THE STRAIN AND THE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH ACROSS
INSURANCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. SOME OF
THE LINE TWO CALL. AFTER MADAM
AND MEMBERS THIS IS MIKE DILLON
REPRESENTING SKI CALIFORNIA I
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY CAL TRAVEL AND OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE FORTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR TOURISM RECOVERY. IS HE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA PLACE
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS THIS NEW
FUNDING ALONG WITH THAT PROVIDED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. WILL HELP
ALL SECTORS OF TOURISM RECOVER
MORE QUICKLY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MODERATOR I
COUNTED THREE HOW MANY MORE DO
WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE. THAT WAS
THE LAST ONE THERE'S NO OTHER
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHTY
THANK YOU SO HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC-
ARE SENATORS CABALLERO ROTH AND
MY VICE CHAIR NIELSEN DO YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON ANY OF THESE ITEMS.
OKAY SO WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR I HAVE
SEPARATED THESE OUT INTO TO
MOTIONS. WE WILL TAKE THE FIRST
MOTION NUMBER ONE- ISSUE NUMBER
ONE- FOR- PR THE TECHNICAL AND
LEGISLATIVE RELATED PROPOSALS IS
THERE A MOTION. MOVED THE MOTION
MOVED BY SENATOR RON. ALL THE
ROLE. KAMLAGER I CABALLERO
NIELSEN NO ROTH FIVE. THAT IS
THAT ONE TWO THREE THREE ONE
THAT GETS OUT THERE IN MY SLOW
MATH WE WILL NOW MOVE TO MOTION
TO WHICH TAKES UP ISSUE NUMBER
TWO THREE AND FOUR TWO IS
COMMISSION ON STATE MANDATES
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF THREE IS
MUNICIPAL STORMWATER IN URBAN
RUNOFF DISCHARGES MANDATE AND
FOR IS AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
WORKLOAD BY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S THEIR MOTION ON
THE FLOOR. WILL MOVE SOMEPLACE
AND OUR COMPANY EURO CALL THE
ROLL. KAMLAGER HI HOW ARE YOU.
NIELSEN AYE ROTH. ALL RIGHT THAT
MOTION GETS OUT WITH FOUR ZERO-
BUT- WE HAVE NO ITEMS ON CALL
THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION ESPECIALLY THE
STAFF. WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING THE
SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR IS
ADJOURNED.